Salut, moi, c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec. Un épisode spécial cette semaine, puisque l'actu n'attend pas.
On casse exceptionnellement le rythme bimensuel pour parler des élections fédérales belges. À la fin du dernier épisode, j'avais annoncé un paquet d'invités, trois invités politiques et un journaliste.
Et pour des raisons logistiques,
il y a eu plusieurs annulations. Et du coup, pour bien faire les choses, je me suis simplement posé une heure avec Frédéric Chardon, journaliste politique de La Libre Belgique, histoire de débriefer les élections fédérales.
J'aurai certainement la chance de recevoir tous ces politiciens dans le futur et ce n'est que partie remise. On retrouve tout de suite Frédéric Chardon.
C'est parti. Bonjour à tous. Nous sommes aujourd'hui dans le bureau de La Libre Belgique avec Frédéric Chardon. Frédéric Chardon, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Tu es journaliste politique depuis 2014, c'est juste ?
Oui, 2013, oui.
Qu'est-ce qui t'a mené, tiens, question que je pose à tous les journalistes, question terriblement bateau, mais les réponses sont toujours intéressantes, je trouve.
Qu'est-ce qui t'a mené à devenir journaliste et plus précisément journaliste politique ?
Oui, ben, à la base, moi, j'ai fait sciences politiques à l'Université de Liège, donc j'avais déjà ça dans le sang, pour l'aspect en tout cas analyse.
Et puis après, j'ai travaillé pendant plusieurs années dans le secteur public, notamment dans l'administration publique fédérale où je m'emmerdais prodigieusement.
Et donc, je ne donnerai pas le nom du ministère où je m'ennuyais, hein, où je m'ennuyais.
Je mettrai en intro, hein.
Non, voilà, c'était aux allocations familiales à l'époque, avant la régionalisation.
Ça va.
Donc c'était particulièrement pénible. Et être là-bas m'a donné finalement un déclic, hein, et je me suis dit : « Je vais refaire une année d'études. »
D'accord.
J'ai fait un master en journalisme à l'UCL. Et puis après, moi, j'ai pu travailler comme journaliste assez rapidement.
D'abord à Liège, hein, je suis Liégeois et j'habite toujours là-bas.
On dit pourtant que le journalisme, c'est un secteur avec beaucoup de précarité, où on trouve, bon, difficilement de l'emploi, où on reste pigiste assez longtemps.
Toi, tu dis, assez facilement, t'as trouvé de l'emploi ?
Au début, c'était très, très, très, oui, non, très dur, hein. C'était très dur, comme tout le monde, comme la plupart des journalistes, surtout en presse écrite.
Les premiers mois, ça aura été la galère, je gagnais très, très, très, très mal ma vie. Et mais ça a duré quelques mois, alors que peut-être pour d'autres, ça peut durer un peu plus longtemps.
Et finalement, après quelques mois, j'ai pu, surtout grâce, enfin, grâce à La Libre, en fait, commencer à travailler pour les pages Régions de La Libre.
Et là, j'ai travaillé à nouveau quelques mois, puis j'ai pu passer en pages nationales, d'abord au service économie, où j'ai travaillé à nouveau quelques mois et j'ai été aspiré, en fait, tout de suite, très rapidement, en politique belge.
Hum, hum. Et qu'est-ce qui explique, parce que donc, quand tu dis ça, ça fait ascension très rapide. T'es parti de reconversion et puis quelques mois après, ou quelques mois, puis quelques mois, puis quelques mois, tu te retrouves
au service politique de La Libre Belgique, au niveau national.
Qu'est-ce qui explique cette ascension aussi rapide ? Est-ce que tu es-
Ben, je dirais que-
Est-ce que tu es incroyablement talentueux ? C'est ça que tu essaies de dire ?
Ouais, je vais répondre de manière modeste. Je vais dire qu'il y avait une série de départs. Je vais répondre à la belge.
Voilà, une série de départs qui ont fait qu'il y avait un vide à combler. Et donc du coup, voilà, la rédaction en chef de l'époque s'est dit : « Tiens, qui pourrait-on mettre à ce poste ? »
Tu es mieux que le vide, donc tu as trouvé une place.
Voilà, c'était mieux que le vide et ils ont pensé à Frédéric Chardon alors.
Yes, OK. Alors, on va évidemment principalement aujourd'hui parler des élections qui ont eu lieu il y a dix jours ici, en Belgique.
Question simple pour commencer : qu'est-ce que tu retiens de cette campagne, pour ces élections 2019 ?
De la campagne ?
Oui, qu'est-ce que tu retiens comme fait d'actualité qui t'ont marqué ? Ouais, principalement de la campagne, disons, ouais.
Alors, ben, c'est assez évident, hein, mais je dirais, dans les derniers moments,
ce tract Ecolo, évidemment, parce que pour moi, ça... Je veux pas surinterpréter, mais ça a vraiment, pour moi, été un élément de basculement de la campagne.
D'accord.
Dans les derniers moments, on savait très bien que les électeurs risquaient d'avoir ces accusations de communautarisme contre Ecolo en tête au moment d'aller voter, dans les urnes le dimanche.
Et donc, quand on a vu que cette information rebondissait, que ce tract avait été distribué sur un marché à Laeken, hein, tout de suite, on s'est dit que ça allait avoir un impact.
Et en effet, ça a eu un impact médiatique très important.
Pour rappel,
Laeken, nord-ouest de Bruxelles, communauté musulmane très présente et un tract, oui, que beaucoup ont qualifié et que je vais moi-même qualifier de très communautariste dans son approche, avec, voilà, une série de problématiques comme
l'abattage des animaux sans étourdissement, le port du voile dans les administrations, etc.
Et qui, finalement, résumait les problématiques de la population locale aux problématiques musulmanes et n'évoquait rien d'autre.
Donc certains écologistes avaient décidé de faire un tract où ils rappelaient toutes les positions d'Ecolo en faveur des musulmans, en fait, hein.
Ils les avaient condensées sur un seul et même tract, selon certains, qu'on qualifiait de communautariste. Et donc du coup, ça jetait
une lumière assez crue sur un positionnement d'Ecolo qui n'était pas toujours connu de tous,
en faveur, et enfin, c'est un positionnement légitime, certainement, en faveur du respect, peut-être, des traditions ou des coutumes ou des habitudes de certains,
de certains Belges musulmans ou de personnes
musulmanes en Belgique.
Tout le monde n'avait pas conscience de ça, à mon avis, dans les petites campagnes wallonnes. Et donc, hum... Et donc on a senti qu'Ecolo, qui était placé très, très haut par les sondages,
ça correspondait à la réalité au moment où les sondages l'ont mesuré.
On a eu le sentiment, et ça s'est avéré juste par la suite, qu'Ecolo n'allait pas pouvoir profiter de la vague verte qu'on avait annoncée, de cette vague climat qu'on avait annoncée, qui devait les porter en tête, partout.
Eh bien, voilà, ce tract a vraiment fait pour moi basculer la campagne. C'était un des éléments du basculement de la campagne.
Je rajouterais à côté de ça, un autre élément qui a fait basculer la campagne, c'est la campagne assez forte, assez violente même, diront certains, qu'a menée le MR contre Ecolo.
Ça, c'était un choix tactique des libéraux qui a vraiment fait basculer aussi la campagne à nouveau dans le sens de l'affaiblissement des écologistes.
Oui. Ça, c'est effectivement les deux points que j'avais le plus retenus concernant cette campagne. On va peut-être commencer par le Mouvement Réformateur.
On a pu voir ces derniers mois
certaines crises identitaires. Je ne sais pas si tu partages ce constat, mais dans la stratégie du Mouvement Réformateur, puisque historiquement, on voyait,
on a entendu, il me semble, ces dernières années, Olivier Chastel défendre une idée qu'il fallait une droite plus dure au sein du Mouvement Réformateur.
On a vu entrer dans le parti des personnalités comme-
Chastel, je crois pas hein.
C'était pas Chastel ?
Non.
Non, je dois confondre alors. Mais en tout cas, il y a eu par exemple l'entrée d'Étienne Dujardin, qui lui défend une version francophone de la N-VA, une droite beaucoup plus dure.
On a vu une scission avec le départ d'Alain Destexhe. Et voilà, il y avait même certaines personnalités du Mouvement Réformateur comme
Denis Ducarme, qui était chargé de représenter le front, entre guillemets, N-VA du Mouvement Réformateur, avec
cette idée de : voilà, moi, je veux bien qu'on m'appelle le Francken wallon, par exemple.
Donc, clairement, une défense sur la droite, un raffermissement sur sa droite, de peur de voir un électorat fuir, par exemple, chez Alain Destexhe ou au Parti populaire.
Finalement, elle n'a pas du tout eu lieu puisque ces partis-là ont fait un bide absolu. Comment est-ce qu'il faut analyser cette situation ?
Est-ce que la défense a fonctionné ? Est-ce qu'ils ont bien fait de se défendre sur leur droite ? Ou bien est-ce qu'en fait, il n'y a jamais eu un challenge, une fuite des électeurs sur leur droite et que-
Non. Alors, donc, il y a eu un challenge, même si le top du parti dira que c'est pas le cas, mais je peux garantir qu'il y a eu un challenge.
Il y a eu une grosse inquiétude des libéraux, au moment où Alain Destexhe menaçait de créer sa propre formation, hein, c'était quelques semaines avant les élections.
Et donc, les libéraux, le top du parti, Charles Michel, Didier Reynders, ils ont tout fait, tout fait jusqu'au dernier moment, jusqu'à la dernière minute, pour éviter qu'Alain Destexhe ne quitte le parti.
Parce qu'ils savaient très bien que ça allait affaiblir encore plus le parti sur sa droite. Et donc, ils voulaient éviter ça, ne serait-ce que perdre 2, 3 % de plus, ça peut être énorme pour un parti hein.
C'était pas forcément la moitié du parti qui partait avec Alain Destexhe, bien entendu, mais il y avait une crainte de perdre 2, 3 % et 2, 3 %, c'est ce qui fait qu'on est premier ou deuxième ou troisième hein.
C'est très, très important pour un parti.
Donc, il y avait une véritable crainte. Donc, en effet, ces derniers mois, à quelques occasions,
la ligne officielle du parti avait été réaffirmée sur certains thèmes vis-à-vis desquels les libéraux étaient plutôt mal à l'aise auparavant, notamment le thème de l'immigration.
Et donc, le parti a dû réfléchir à essayer de définir une ligne qui soit quand même suffisamment à droite tout en restant libérale.
Évidemment, c'est toute l'équation complexe à résoudre pour le MR, c'est que c'est un parti libéral.
Donc, il ne peut pas être trop conservateur non plus, notamment sur le plan de l'immigration, parce que c'est contraire à sa doctrine politique de base.
Donc c'est voilà. Et alors, le parti a pas mal réussi à définir une ligne où il disait finalement : notre ligne sur la migration, notamment, c'est la ligne Francken.
Ah oui, OK, mais la ligne Francken sans le populisme qui va avec, sans les tweets ravageurs, sans l'exploitation médiatique outrancière-
Alors ça, pour le coup, c'est vraiment du positionnement en termes d'électoralisme, plus que...
Non, c'est parce que... non, ça correspond à leur mode de pensée. Donc c'est...
Ben c'est pas : comment est-ce qu'on peut se défendre d'être la ligne Francken sans ce qui définit le personnage en grande partie, c'est-à-dire ses sorties ?
Parce que la ligne Francken, c'était la ligne du gouvernement fédéral dirigée par Charles Michel. Donc le MR assumait pleinement, en fait, la ligne du gouvernement, pour être plus précis.
C'était assez essentiel, ouais.
C'est-à-dire la ligne Francken dans la gestion des dossiers,
mais sans souscrire au positionnement, au mode de communication, à la violence verbale ou aux tweets ravageurs que Theo Francken a pu diffuser tout au long de la législature, bien entendu hein.
Mais le MR a rappelé à plusieurs reprises, il s'est rendu compte, en fait, de législature, qu'il devait rappeler à plusieurs reprises que oui, il était d'accord avec la politique migratoire,
qui était menée par le gouvernement fédéral, qui était celle donc incarnée par Theo Francken, mais qui était en fait plus ou moins la même,
que celle que menait Maggie De Block sous le gouvernement Di Rupo hein.
En fait, Francken n'a pas révolutionné la gestion des dossiers migratoires. Oui, bon, il a apporté quelques nuances, mais la gestion de fond n'était pas très différente de la ligne De Block.
Donc, autrement dit, toutes les controverses, oui, puisque c'est un sujet qui est hautement controversé, les questions migratoires, les questions des familles enfermées dans des centres.
Est-ce que ça veut dire que finalement, quelle que soit la famille politique, que ce soit sous un Di Rupo, que ce soit sous un Francken, un gouvernement libéral,
finalement, la même politique qui est en marche et que finalement, c'est surtout une question de communication, une question de positionnement ?
Comment est-ce que tu perçois ça ?
Oui, c'est vrai. Bon, par exemple, le Parti socialiste, pour prendre l'échiquier à gauche, sur les questions migratoires, c'est mon impression, je le sens plutôt mal à l'aise.
Je sens bien qu'il n'est pas,
qu'il ne pourrait pas assumer une politique ouvertement et publiquement très généreuse vis-à-vis des immigrés, parce que au PS, ils savent bien que ce ne serait pas forcément compris par une partie, une grande partie de leur électorat.
On peut envoyer le même reproche ou la même remarque au PTB. Donc ça, ce que je dis, c'est mon analyse. Le seul parti qui me semble plus à l'aise vis-à-vis des immigrés et de ce positionnement sur la gauche, c'est Ecolo.
Je crois qu'Ecolo est plus clair par rapport à ça. Ils sont plutôt, voilà, ils le disent ouvertement, qu'ils sont pour des régularisations des personnes illégales ou des sans-papiers, comme on dit, qui travaillent, par exemple.
C'était dans leur programme. Donc ils le reconnaissaient ouvertement.
Mh. Donc ça, c'est pour parler des sujets sensibles plutôt à droite. Les questions de l'immigration, effectivement, étaient au cœur de la campagne, par exemple, d'Alain Destexhe.
Sur leur gauche, là c'est plus clair qu'ils ont perdu une partie de leur électorat. Comment est-ce que tu expliques cette transition d'un parti centre-droit vers un parti... Alors ça, c'est intéressant.
Quand j'avais interviewé Gilles Vanden Burre, il y avait clairement un axe de dire : « Ben nous, on est à l'équidistance des autres partis.
On est aussi proche du Mouvement Réformateur que du PS. » Ce qui est un petit peu la ligne de Jean-Michel Javaux. D'autres, au sein du parti, ont plutôt l'air de défendre l'idée qu'Ecolo est clairement à gauche.
D'ailleurs, tu en parlais il y a un instant comme étant un parti de gauche.
Oui.
Comment est-ce que tu perçois cette transition d'un parti libéral centre droit ?
On parle du MR ?
Donc la transition d'une partie de l'électorat du Mouvement Réformateur-
Ah oui, oui
...qui est parti. Donc le Mouvement Réformateur a perdu un petit peu sur sa gauche, disons.
Oui, oui.
Ou même beaucoup.
Ah oui, ben c'est-
Comment est-ce que tu analyses cette migration électorale ?
Des électeurs du MR vers Ecolo. Donc en fait, c'est parce que, on ne le sait pas forcément, mais le MR et Ecolo partagent en partie un même électorat, qui est un électorat-
D'un point de vue socioéconomique, sociographique.
Exactement. D'un point de vue socioéconomique, d'un point de vue culturel, d'un point de vue
éducationnel. Donc en fait, c'est plutôt des gens d'un bon niveau, qui ont souvent fait des études supérieures, qui gagnent leur vie, voilà.
Et ces personnes peuvent voter, de manière assez caractéristique, soit pour le MR, soit pour Ecolo, et changer d'avis au-
Au dernier moment
...au dernier moment ou en fonction des époques, en fonction de l'air du temps.
Et c'est peut-être ce qui s'est passé avec le tract, alors.
Et donc la grande crainte des libéraux, et c'est ce qui était annoncé à juste titre par les sondages, c'est que les libéraux allaient perdre du côté de leur aile centriste vers Ecolo,
justement, cet électorat volatile qui passe facilement d'Ecolo au MR ou de MR à Ecolo.
Et en effet, le MR a décidé de faire un rouleau compresseur durant la campagne, extrêmement fort sur Ecolo, pour dénoncer aussi les éléments dans son programme sur le plan socioéconomique,
qui pouvaient amener, selon les libéraux, à une rage taxatoire, pour reprendre leur vieille expression.
Leur terme, oui, oui.
Et donc ils ont tapé sur
cet élément-là aussi pour rappeler à leur électorat, peut-être plus bourgeois, tenté par Ecolo, donc certains diront les bobos,
qu'ils votaient peut-être pour un parti, s'ils décidaient de voter pour Ecolo, pour un parti qui, sur le plan fiscal, par exemple,
n'allait pas forcément favoriser, comment dire, les gens qui ont du patrimoine ou les gens qui ont envie d'investir en bourse, voilà.
Il y a une vérité derrière ces accusations ou pas ?
Oui, il y a une vérité, bien sûr. Donc Ecolo, dans son programme officiel, donc je ne dévoile rien, a un impôt de crise, donc c'est une taxe sur le patrimoine, qui est prévue.
C'est un impôt sur la fortune, en fait, de 1 à 1,5 %, au-dessus de, donc de mémoire, c'est au-dessus du million d'euros, hors habitation principale.
Donc ce, bon c'est pas pour tout le monde, évidemment.
Oui, non, mais enfin voilà, ça ne concerne pas les bobos, pour le coup.
Bah certains d'entre eux, bien, en tout cas.
Oui, certains d'entre eux.
Pas tous, pas tous, bien sûr. Voilà, mais en tout cas, ça donne une tonalité politique au programme plutôt à gauche. Il y avait aussi cette-- Donc le MR a beaucoup reproché à Ecolo de défendre la péréquation cadastrale, donc,
qui aurait abouti à terme à l'augmentation du prix quand tu immobilier.
Sans rentrer dans les détails-
Ouais, c'est très technique ça pour le coup.
...techniques et fiscaux, je vais pas rentrer là-dedans.
Donc voilà, donc en tout cas, je ne donne ni raison à l'un ou l'autre, mais le MR a voulu mettre en évidence les éléments réels dans le programme d'Ecolo,
qui, sur le plan socioéconomique, n'étaient pas forcément favorables, je dirais, aux classes moyennes, aux classes moyennes supérieures.
Mh. Donc ça, c'est pour un petit peu faire le tour sur la droite et sur la gauche du Mouvement Réformateur.
Quelque chose qui m'a frappé, il y a une étude qui est sortie la semaine dernière, je crois, de l'ULB, qui analysait un petit peu les profils des électeurs de chaque parti à Bruxelles.
Il se montrait par exemple que l'électorat du Mouvement Réformateur à Bruxelles est composé à 38 % de catholiques, alors que le CDH, quant à lui,
continue sa lente chute depuis, oui, depuis la fin des années 90 hein.
Donc est-ce qu'il y a une fuite des électeurs catholiques du CDH vers le Mouvement Réformateur ?
Alors oui, mais alors c'est pas nouveau du tout.
Oui, mais je sais.
Ça a commencé dans les années 60, au début des années 60.
Les libéraux
avaient lancé une grande campagne électorale d'affichage
où on voyait des fidèles qui sortaient de la messe et le slogan électoral des libéraux à ce moment-là, c'était, je sais plus la phrase exacte, mais on disait : « Vous aussi, vous pouvez voter pour les libéraux.
» Donc vous, chrétiens, vous, catholiques, vous pouvez voter pour les libéraux. Nous ne sommes pas des laïcards avec le couteau entre les dents,
mais au contraire, nous sommes ouverts à toutes les sensibilités, y compris à la foi chrétienne.
Et donc, à partir de ce virage dans les années 60, les libéraux se sont de plus en plus ouverts et ont de plus en plus recruté des lecteurs sociologiquement chrétiens ou pratiquants.
Et donc aujourd'hui, selon les derniers chiffres que j'ai en tête, en gros, la moitié de l'électorat libéral du MR est de sociologiquement caractérisé comme chrétien.
C'est ça.
Et l'autre moitié, de l'électorat de base hein, et l'autre moitié est, disons, laïque ou athée ou agnostique, quoi, pas chrétienne.
Par contre, au niveau des élites du parti,
là, c'est un petit peu plus caractéristique. Depuis le 19e siècle, en fait, l'élite des dirigeants du Parti libéral est plutôt laïque, parce que proche des loges maçonniques, en fait hein.
C'est ça, oui. J'allais dire, effectivement, au 19e siècle, c'était vraiment les guerres des écoles entre le Parti libéral, Parti catholique.
Voilà. Et donc le Parti libéral, le MR, en a gardé quand même plutôt une tendance au niveau de l'élite des dirigeants à plutôt être dans des loges maçonniques plutôt que à la messe quoi.
On pense par exemple à un Richard Miller, par exemple.
Richard Miller par exemple, oui, oui, oui.
Ouais. Et donc finalement cette transition de l'électorat, ça ne se ressent pas à la tête. On ne ressent pas d'idéologie catholique-
Non, pas vraiment.
À la tête du parti.
Pas du tout, puisque le Parti libéral en Belgique,
tu l'as expliqué tout à l'heure, le Parti libéral au XIXe siècle a été créé en 1846, pour être exact, à l'initiative des loges maçonniques,
pour donner un contrepoids politique au pouvoir très important qu'avaient les catholiques à l'époque.
Ça, c'était il y a deux cents ans.
Mais c'est resté. On a, les libéraux ont gardé comme ça, dans... Et puis c'est lié au libéralisme aussi en tant que doctrine politique, hein.
Mais ça, ça me surprend que,
et je ne sais pas, on pourrait penser par exemple
au temps au XIXe siècle, on voyait une espèce de guerre systématique récurrente entre voilà d'un côté les écoles laïques, les écoles catholiques et on veut
supprimer les écoles catholiques qui sont des usines à électeurs pour le Parti catholique et tout ça.
Et aujourd'hui, on voit les libéraux presque en train de défendre ce, ben par exemple, hein, Destexhe du temps où il était au Mouvement réformateur, défendait très fort
cet enseignement traditionnel catholique, il faisait des sorties contre le burkini, etc.
Oui.
On sent quand même un petit peu que l'électorat, ce changement au niveau de l'électorat a une influence au niveau de la tête du parti.
Enfin, moi, ça me surprend.
Oui, oui, certainement. En effet, pour défendre le réseau libre, c'est pas forcément la position que les libéraux auraient pu défendre au XIXe siècle, bien entendu, c'est bien juste.
Mais simplement, ils défendent aussi l'évolution de leur propre électorat, c'est clair.
C'est sûr.
Qui fréquente peut-être plus facilement le réseau libre que le réseau public aujourd'hui. Il y a peut-être aussi une volonté de défendre la possibilité d'un choix.
Ça, c'est très libéral aussi.
Oui.
La possibilité d'un choix pour les parents, de choisir l'enseignement officiel ou bien le réseau libre et défendre la garantie que tout le mon-- qu'on aura un choix, qu'il y aura pas un seul canal d'enseignement,
en communauté française.
Donc le libéralisme d'un point de vue économique, d'un point de vue libre choix de l'école s'oppose là presque avec la doctrine libérale d'origine des loges maçonniques.
Oui, oui, c'est vrai, mais sauf qu'aujourd'hui, il y a plus la guerre scolaire, quoi.
Oui, c'est ça, oui.
Aujourd'hui, je veux dire, les problèmes du XIXe ne sont plus du tout ceux d'aujourd'hui. Donc la guerre scolaire, tout ça,
l'opposition violente entre le pouvoir catholique et le pouvoir libéral maçonnique, tout ça, c'est du passé.
Ça n'existe plus.
Mais je veux dire, justement, enfin, parce que là, on fait une petite parenthèse.
Oui.
On va retourner sur les élections dans un instant, mais une petite pa, pour clôturer cette petite parenthèse sur les écoles.
Les sorties, justement, contre le réseau libre confessionnel, je les entends plutôt dans la bouche d'un Rudy Demotte qui va expliquer que
il aimerait bien voir la suppression du cours de religion et voir la sortie d'un enseignement dogmatique et voir une plus grande importance au cours de citoyenneté, etc.
Oui, ben c'est sûr que le Parti socialiste, qui est d'ailleurs, à la base une branche du Parti libéral, c'est la branche progressiste du Parti libéral qui s'est décrochée également à la fin du XIXe siècle.
Ben c'est sûr que le Parti socialiste, lui, n'a pas cette, n'a pas besoin d'être trop précautionneux vis-à-vis du réseau libre.
Il peut y aller à fond sur le réseau public. Oui, c'est vrai, c'est vrai.
Donc pour revenir sur ce qu'on disait sur la lente chute du parti CDH, donc les anciens catholiques, c'est quoi ?
C'est donc les libéraux ont été piquer les électeurs au CDH à partir des années 60. Et petit à petit, l'électorat a fui vers le Mouvement réformateur.
Et plutôt que de, il ne s'est pas vraiment renouvelé chez le CDH, si je comprends bien.
L'électorat de l'ancien PC n'est pas parti que vers les libéraux.
Chez Écolo aussi.
L'aile peut-être plus droitière du PC a pu être tentée par les libéraux, mais il y a aussi des gens qui sont partis, je pense, également chez Écolo.
Oui, c'est sûr.
Parce que les Écolos ont une dualité au sein de leur formation, qui est composée également d'un courant progressiste laïque et un courant plus centriste et sociologiquement chrétien.
Jean-Michel Javaux disait par exemple ouvertement qu'il était catholique.
Bien entendu. Voilà, c'est l'exemple le plus parfait, c'est Jean-Michel Javaux, centriste, pro-entreprises privées, ouvertement catholique, en effet, même royaliste d'ailleurs.
C'est pas vraiment la norme officielle du parti, hein. Je suis pas certain que Zaki Akatabi soit tout à fait d'accord avec les positions de Jean-Michel Javaux.
Voilà, ça montre bien la dualité au sein d'Écolo. Et Écolo a récupéré pas mal de l'électorat, en tout cas une partie de l'ancien électorat plus progressiste, préoccupé d'environnement, de l'ancien PC.
Et donc c'était aussi une fuite des électeurs CDH des deux côtés, quoi. Je dirais un côté qui part vers Écolo et l'autre côté qui part vers le MR.
Et donc aujourd'hui, il reste un parti qui est en grande difficulté, je pense, qui est dans une difficulté structurelle, une décroissance structurelle, comme les autres partis traditionnels d'ailleurs, mais je crois que c'est très marqué chez le CDH.
D'ailleurs, au moment où on parle,
on vient d'apprendre que le CDH renonçait à gouverner et Maxime Prévot vient d'annoncer que son parti allait dans l'opposition à tous les niveaux de pouvoir, quoi qu'il arrive, et qu'il lançait une grande refondation du parti.
Ben c'est bien la preuve que le parti est en crise. Alors, vers quoi vont-ils, que vont-ils inventer ?
C'est toute la question.
Je parlais de Javaux, ben voilà, on peut revenir sur l'initiative Échange, hein.
Oui, ça a toujours paru mystérieux, ça. Donc c'est des-
Bon alors ça, on peut en parler.
Oui, oui, on peut en parler. On peut en parler, tout à fait. C'est des politiciens qui viennent un petit peu de tous les partis, donc CDH, Écolo.
Surtout CDH et Écolo, hein.
Oui, c'est ça, oui. Mais on trouve aussi des libéraux, il me semble.
Ben pas beaucoup, hein. Donc, il y en avait pas, en fait, hein. Il y avait l'un ou l'autre, mais qui était parti dès le départ, assez rapidement.
Et puis, il y avait certainement Javaux.
Il y avait Javaux, oui, tout à fait.
Il y avait Didier Gosuin, du Défi. Je sais pas ce qu'il faisait là, mais-
Justement, voilà, c'est-
Les autres, ben ça, je ne me l'explique toujours pas.
C'est ça.
Tous les autres,
tous les autres, c'était des gens du CDH qui étaient là en toute- Alors que Benoît Lutgen, à l'époque président du CDH, savait très bien qu'il participait à ce groupe de réflexion,
qui allait, qui pouvait devenir à un moment donné un nouveau parti politique qui aurait été une recréation,
en version un peu plus verte du CDH, en fait.
Alors peut-être ici, donc voilà, c'est clair. Donc on avait pu révéler tout ça dans La Libre Belgique, hein, il y a quelque temps.
Donc c'était secret ? Tu parles de révéler.
Oui, oui. Ben oui, on a révélé parce que c'était secret, hein. Ça, c'est,
ben voilà, c'est normal.
C'est normal qu'ils avançaient dans le secret, ils n'avaient pas envie que leur initiative soit révélée, parce que c'était une initiative de réflexion politique avec la possibilité d'en faire un parti politique pour les élections 2019.
Alors, quand j'avais pu révéler ça, puisque c'était l'auteur de l'article, il y avait eu beaucoup de démentis.
Et puis finalement, donc moi, j'avais maintenu mes informations parce que j'en étais certain,
parce que j'ai des documents que je n'avais pas pu diffuser à l'époque, qui le prouvaient, voilà, que Échange pouvait devenir un parti.
Et puis, au fur et à mesure, les semaines passant, certains, la citadelle a fini par céder. Certains membres d'Échange ont fini par reconnaître que oui, en effet, il y avait eu une possibilité de créer un parti
à terme, mais que cette possibilité était enterrée.
Alors maintenant que le CDH va se refonder, est-ce que, donc c'est un point d'interrogation, est-ce que, par exemple, Échange va revenir, sous un autre nom, une autre forme,
pour recréer un CDH plus fort et plus vert, pour aller rechercher l'électorat perdu vers Ecolo, comme on vient d'en parler ?
C'est une possibilité.
Mais ça nécessiterait alors un électorat frustré, déçu d'Ecolo, qui voudrait repartir chez ce nouveau parti, Échange.
Est-ce qu'il existe cet électorat un peu catho, un peu CDH, un peu Écolo, qui serait, qui chercherait un mix des deux ?
Est-ce qu'il existe cet électorat ?
Oui, alors, complètement. Il existe. La preuve : il existe, même si je ne l'ai jamais rencontré. Mais il existe.
Il suffit de voir la volatilité des voix qui sont tantôt accordées à Écolo, tantôt reprises à Écolo en fonction des élections.
Lors d'une élection, Écolo cartonne, l'élection d'après, Écolo se ramasse.
C'est ça, tout à fait, ouais.
Donc ça veut dire peu de partis ont une telle volatilité de leur électorat. Donc c'est un gros problème en fait pour Écolo d'avoir cette volatilité.
En 2014, c'est la débâcle. Écolo doit licencier des dizaines et des dizaines de collaborateurs parce qu'ils n'ont plus d'argent, parce qu'ils ont perdu beaucoup de députés.
Ils ne peuvent plus avoir de groupes dans certaines assemblées parce qu'ils ne sont plus assez nombreux. Donc c'est très, très grave.
Et puis ici, ben voilà, ils reprogressent à nouveau, pas dans l'ampleur.
Petite vague verte.
Petite vague verte, une vaguelette verte, mais réelle. Le parti, enfin, surtout à Bruxelles-Capitale, beaucoup moins en Wallonie.
Mais à Bruxelles, là, il y a une véritable performance des Verts. Alors,
le danger pour Écolo, c'est en 2024, lorsqu'on revotera, sauf si on revote avant vu la situation, en 2024, le grand danger, c'est que Écolo reperde ce qu'il vient de prendre.
Ils le savent très bien. Donc c'est la preuve qu'il y a une grande volatilité de l'électorat Écolo, mais qui peut aller vers le PS, vers le MR, vers le CDH, au gré des circonstances, ou repartir vers Écolo.
Quand on parle de volatilité d'électorat, ça fait penser-- parce qu'évidemment, on fait la comparaison avec les autres partis traditionnels CDH, MR, PS.
Ça fait penser à la question de la pilarisation de la Belgique, où on est, pour certains, ancrés, enfermés dans un pilier.
On parle du pilier socialiste, pilier libéral, pilier catholique, avec les écoles, la mutualité, et ainsi de suite, la presse même, on y reviendra.
Les syndicats.
Oui, voilà, tout à fait. Est-ce que cette volatilité, on l'attribue en partie au fait que, ben ça n'est pas un pilier, le pilier vert, ça n'existe pas vraiment.
On n'est pas enfermé dans un pilier quand on est électeur chez Écolo ?
Oui, c'est vrai, c'est une bonne remarque. Écolo n'a pas vraiment de pilier. Enfin, quoique certains vont dire que non.
Ils vont dire : « Mais si, regardez le secteur associatif, le secteur des ONG. » Ça aussi, c'est une forme de pilier.
C'est une forme-- C'est un terreau qui porte Écolo, mais pas avec la même force.
Est-ce qu'on est nombreux à être actifs dans une ONG ? Je ne sais pas.
Oui, c'est ça. Mais pas avec la même force. Ce terreau ne donne pas de croissance avec la même force à Écolo que les anciens piliers peuvent aider les partis traditionnels.
Mais c'est en train-
Mais ils sont entrés dans le secteur, disons, activiste sur le terrain. Et voilà, on peut être, voilà.
Clairement, ça, on peut pas...
C'est sûr, ouais.
Il y a un lien très clair entre les ONG. Il suffit de voir les prises de position de Greenpeace pendant la campagne. Ça a été reproché d'ailleurs par le MR.
Voilà, Greenpeace a quand même plutôt soutenu Écolo. On peut l'imaginer, ceci dit, hein, mais... Mais alors, je voulais juste ajouter un élément, c'est que on parle de la pilarisation de la société.
C'est pas facile à dire, mais cette pilarisation a tendance à disparaître.
Oui, c'est sûr, oui. Au bénéfice d'Écolo, oui.
Au bénéfice d'Écolo. Donc, les anciens piliers n'ont plus le même poids qu'avant, à commencer par la partie politique de ces piliers, donc les partis.
Il suffit de voir l'évolution du vote ces dernières années. Les partis traditionnels n'ont quasiment fait que régresser.
Donc le CDH PC, le MR, ex-PRL et le PS n'ont fait que perdre vers des nouveaux partis.
Pareil du côté néerlandophone.
Exactement. Donc, du côté francophone, en l'occurrence, ces partis traditionnels n'ont fait que perdre vers l'émergence de nouveaux partis tels que Écolo et puis plus récemment vers le PTB.
Oui. Et alors, puisqu'on parle du côté néerlandophone, est-ce que la N-VA, c'est aussi un nouvel acteur non pilarisé ?
Est-ce que lui aussi connaît ce problème que connaît Écolo ? C'est-à-dire ne repose pas sur un pilier et a donc un électorat qui peut fuir un peu plus vers la droite, par exemple ?
Oui, en effet. Donc c'est bien ça. C'est ce qu'on vient de voir ici. La N-VA a reperdu une partie de l'électorat qu'elle avait siphonné au Belang en 2014.
Elle vient de le reperdre quasiment totalement, ici ou en partie, en grande partie. Donc la grande force de Bart De Wever
Et l'explication du succès finalement hors norme de la N-VA en quelques années dans ce pays, c'est d'avoir compris qu'il pouvait ramener les électeurs de l'extrême droite vers la droite démocratique.
Et c'est tout l'intérêt de l'offre politique qu'a apporté la N-VA en Flandre. C'était une ligne de droite assumée, libérale conservatrice, flamingante, mais finalement sans excès, en fait. Enfin, si, si.
Ça dépend des politiciens.
Ça dépend des points de vue, mais moi, je peux le dire au journaliste politique, c'est une ligne flamingante, mais sans excès.
La preuve, c'est qu'ils viennent de gouverner pendant plus de quatre ans au fédéral sans réclamer—
En fermant la porte.
En fermant la porte à une réforme de l'État pendant toute une législature. Et puis à la fin, ils sont partis, mais c'est pas sur une question institutionnelle.
Ils sont partis sur le pacte de Marrakech. Donc, ce que je veux dire, c'est que je ne dis pas, évidemment—
Pas d'excès flaminguants, mais quand même quelques excès.
Ben ça dépend des points de vue, mais en tout cas par rapport à des séparatistes purs et durs, des nationalistes intransigeants et des—
Tout est relatif, oui.
Tout est relatif. Des séparatistes purs et durs n'auraient jamais accepté de gouverner dans un état fédéral sans avoir une réforme de l'État.
Des séparatistes purs et durs n'auraient pas envoyé Jan Jambon comme candidat Premier ministre d'un pays qu'ils voudraient détruire.
Donc c'est ça que je veux dire quand la N-VA n'est pas si flamingante que ça. En tout cas, dans son discours, elle l'est peut-être, mais dans les faits, elle ne l'est pas toujours.
Et ça fait quand même plusieurs années qu'elle ne l'est pas vraiment.
Est-ce que ça n'est pas...
Alors là, je parle évidemment, je fais un petit peu l'avocat du diable, le cynique, mais est-ce que ça n'est pas une stratégie pour se dédiaboliser aux yeux de certains,
certains conservateurs, certains qui défendent une Belgique unie, de voir, tiens, ce parti
travaille bien, ce parti n'est pas extrême, ce parti n'est pas un flaminguant excessif, n'est pas un parti flaminguant excessif.
Donc si, c'est-à-dire la ligne de Bart De Wever, c'est apporter à la Flandre ce qu'il a l'impression que la Flandre veut.
Et Bart De Wever a l'impression, et jusqu'à présent il s'était pas trop trompé, que la Flandre voulait plutôt une politique de droite.
Il a offert cette politique de droite en infléchissant la ligne de la N-VA vers quelque chose de plus libéral sur le plan économique, bon, et de plus conservateur sur l'aspect sécuritaire, sur l'aspect migratoire.
Mais Bart De Wever sait aussi que, d'après les derniers sondages, il n'y a que cinq pour cent des Flamands qui sont séparatistes.
Donc lui, il ne va pas ruer dans les brancards et faire une—
Campagne là-dessus.
Une campagne destructrice sur la séparation, l'explosion de la Belgique, alors qu'il sait très bien que les Flamands, dans leur très très grande majorité, n'ont pas envie d'une séparation pure et dure.
Pendant cette campagne électorale, qui a parlé institution, qui a parlé institutionnel ? Oui, oui, évidemment, il y a bien la N-VA qui a dit à un moment donné ou à un autre : confédéralisme.
Ils en ont parlé, mais ça, c'est leur core business. Ils peuvent pas ne pas en parler, ils peuvent pas ne pas le rappeler.
Mais est-ce qu'on a mené campagne sur la réforme de l'État ? Pas du tout. Pas du tout. On a parlé fiscalité, on a parlé identité, on a parlé migration.
Mais on a parlé surtout socio-économique, en fait, comme toujours. Comme toujours. Et donc la N-VA, qui devrait alors avoir le couteau entre les dents, être un parti nationaliste.
Ben oui, mais en tout cas, dans les faits, ils ont accepté des choses quand même assez étonnantes pour un parti nationaliste, quoi, je sais pas.
Oui, c'est sûr. Et quelque chose qui m'a frappé, moi, c'est que le soir des résultats, on entendait par exemple d'un côté Elio Di Rupo annoncer fièrement que
le PS était grand gagnant de ces élections puisque, voilà, numéro un du côté francophone, alors que bon, en réalité, c'est,
c'est ce qui se passe.
En tout cas oui, ils sont numéro un, c'est pas faux de le dire.
Voilà, c'est ça. Donc dans sa communication, il choisissait plutôt de mettre l'emphase sur le fait qu'ils étaient numéro un plutôt que
sur le fait qu'ils ont le score le plus bas depuis, je ne sais plus, mille neuf cent septante-neuf ou quelque chose comme ça.
Et de l'autre côté de la frontière linguistique, on entendait Bart De Wever, lui aussi numéro un, dire : Ah, nous avons perdu ces élections.
Oui, c'est très, très frappant, ça.
Oui. Comment est-ce que tu expliques ce choix de communication de la part de Bart De Wever ?
Ben je crois que c'est lié aussi à deux styles. C'est lié aux hommes, c'est lié au style personnel des deux présidents.
Bart De Wever, il,
voilà, parfois, il aime être cash, se montrer cash parce qu'il sait que ça va marcher. Et plutôt que jouer la langue de bois et tourner autour du pot, ben il préfère dire : On a perdu les élections et on l'assume.
Voilà, ça peut plaire à une partie de l'électorat, cette déclaration un peu virile qui assume. Et Elio Di Rupo, ben c'est pas vraiment l'homme des grandes déclarations.
C'est très rare que Elio Di Rupo provoque un clash dans ses déclarations. Donc, il va avoir plutôt tendance à être sur la défensive, à avoir une ligne, une stratégie défensive, à en dire le moins possible.
Elio Di Rupo, il est comme un sphinx, il—
Il fait jamais d'exclusif sur le plateau, par exemple.
Si, si, il l'a fait.
Si, il l'a fait ?
Ben Didier Reynders s'en souvient, je pense, à cet ordre deux mille neuf.
Autrefois, oui, oui.
Elio Di Rupo avait, par surprise, mais c'est peut-être le seul exemple,
avait, je crois que c'était en direct face à Didier Reynders, qui était encore président, oui, qui était encore président du MR, avait annoncé que le PS refuserait de s'allier au MR après les élections.
Donc là, Didier Reynders avait été fort surpris parce que ça, voilà, ça perturbait complètement le cours de l'interview, du duel pendant la campagne.
Mais à part cette déclaration, à part lors de cette scène bien particulière, Elio Di Rupo a plutôt toujours été d'une extrême prudence dans ses déclarations.
D'ailleurs, voilà, je peux le confier, Elio Di Rupo n'est pas la personnalité politique la plus amusante à interroger parce que il—
Beaucoup d'humour.
Voilà, j'imagine s'il y a des journalistes qui écoutent ce podcast, ils souriront en entendant ma phrase, je pense.
Oui, on s'en doute un petit peu. Mais donc, tu attribues cette phrase, cette façon de communiquer de Bart De Wever, comment est-ce que tu l'expliques ?
Ben je l'ai dit, c'est le style politique, je pense.
Style politique, tout simplement.
Oui, c'est un style politique. La N-VA se définit, alors, est-ce que c'est vrai ou pas ? Est-ce que c'est conforme à la réalité ou pas ?
Ça, moi, je vais pas trancher ça ici. Mais la N-VA se définit comme un parti anti-establishment.
C'est sûr.
Alors, certains diront bof, mais voilà, en tout cas, c'est leur ligne.
Oui.
C'est leur ligne. Un parti qui dit les choses, qui est cash, qui ne tourne pas autour du pot. Eux disent : Nous, on veut défendre notre identité, nos valeurs.
Enfin, qu'est-ce qu'on met là-dedans ? On ne sait pas bien, mais enfin, ils le disent clairement. Et donc ils veulent séduire une partie de l'électorat qui a envie d'entendre des choses cash,
qui a envie d'entendre des choses qui ne ressemblent pas à la langue de bois habituelle de la rue de la Loi.
Et les Flamands aiment bien ça, je pense.
Il y a vraiment ce côté oui, brutal, je trouve, dans la communication de Bart De Wever parfois. Je sais pas si ça te parle ou pas du tout.
Si, brutal, oui, sûrement.
Oui.
Oui, il est cash et brutal, ça, c'est clair. Il a tenu des propos qui étaient cash. Je sais pas si c'était brutaux, allez.
Bon, ça a pu l'être parfois.
Un exemple, magnifique transition, un exemple qui symbolise bien ce côté brutal de Bart De Wever, c'était la veille des élections, en fait, le 25 juin, je crois que c'était dans un média flamand, VTM, je pense.
Il était face à un élu socialiste flamand et à Tom Van Grieken sur une place, je crois que c'était à Gand, en Flandre.
Et il a traité monsieur Van Grieken de bouffon. Je ne sais pas si... Oui, voilà, donc là, on est à fond dans le côté brutal de...
Oui, là, il s'est emporté et de mémoire, il s'est excusé, je pense, après.
Oui, ils ont échangé de la bière quelques jours après.
Oui, oui. Il a justement—
Sur base des résultats aux élections, alors, quoi.
Oui, c'est ça. Donc les phrases où on s'emporte, tout le monde en débat, ce n'est pas toujours contrôlé.
Il y a d'autres exemples—
En Belgique, c'est quand même plus rare.
C'est plus rare, mais d'autres exemples en politique belge malgré tout. Mais c'est sûr, voilà, je veux pas dire le contraire.
C'est vrai que les déclarations de Bart De Wever sont assez cash ou peuvent sembler brutales pour certains. C'est vrai, mais j'ai en tête des déclarations tout aussi brutales d'autres personnalités politiques qui n'avaient rien à envier à—
C'est vrai que du côté des écolos, on traitait la N-VA de nazis, donc c'est pas tellement différent, en fait.
En tout cas, c'est très fort. Voilà, on a tous en tête
la petite construction, la petite image que les jeunes écolos avaient fabriquée et a diffusée sur les réseaux sociaux, où on voyait Theo Francken déguisé en soldat allemand de la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Voilà, c'est une manière de faire passer un message politique qui est plutôt brutal également. Donc, je crois que la brutalité, elle est inhérente à la politique et elle n'est pas le fait de la seule N-VA.
Mais donc, puisqu'on parle de monsieur Van Grieken et du Vlaams Belang, cette montée du Vlaams Belang qu'on avait déjà vue en 2004, donc c'est le Zwarte Zondag, cet électorat Vlaams Belang, qui est-il ?
D'où vient-il ? Pourquoi vote-t-il Vlaams Belang ? Quels sont leurs réseaux ?
Bon alors ça, je crois que les politologues n'ont pas fini d'analyser le résultat des élections. Donc, je vais juste donner mon impression.
Je vais donner mon impression. J'ai pas fait d'analyse scientifique à ce stade. Il y en aura, ça va venir, mais je ne l'ai pas fait à ce stade.
On ne l'a pas fait à ce stade, l'analyse de l'électorat Vlaams Belang. On pense néanmoins qu'il y a une tendance de l'électorat Vlaams Belang à avoir fui la N-VA pour l'extrême droite, pour des raisons sociales. En fait,
le Vlaams Belang, ces dernières années, a adopté la stratégie de Marine Le Pen en France, qui est de proposer, au-delà de la ligne dure sur la migration,
une ligne plutôt sociale, plutôt à gauche sur le plan socio-économique, pour dire : Attention, la mondialisation—
Une ligne gilet jaune, presque.
Oui, avant l'heure. Une gil—
C'est ça.
Gilet jaune avant l'heure, avant que l'expression ne soit popularisée.
On va s'en parler hein.
Voilà. Et d'ailleurs, Marine Le Pen a été associée à plusieurs reprises par le Vlaams Belang lors de colloques. J'avais pu assister—
Oui, il y avait même une vidéo, par le Vlaams Belang et Marine Le Pen où elle expliquait que
elle ne connaissait absolument pas monsieur Modrikamen, qu'elle n'en avait jamais entendu parler, que le Parti populaire était complètement dissocié.
Parce que visiblement, alors ça, je sais pas si tu t'y connais là-dedans. Moi, je connais très peu le Parti populaire, mais visiblement, une espèce de petite guerre entre le Vlaams Belang et le Parti populaire.
Visiblement, ils ne se savaient pas du tout. Est-ce que tu sais pourquoi ? J'ai toujours trouvé ça curieux.
Oui, ben donc en fait, il y a eu un clash récemment.
Donc je vais pas refaire toute l'histoire, mais donc Steve Bannon, l'ancien conseiller de Donald Trump, est arrivé avec ses gros sabots, mais en tout cas, c'est l'origine du clash récent,
est arrivé avec ses gros sabots en Europe pour essayer de fédérer les droites populistes et l'extrême droite un peu partout.
Il se trouve que l'association qu'il a créée en Europe pour fédérer cette droite radicale et cette extrême droite européenne était dirigée ou est toujours dirigée par Michael Modrikamen.
Ce que peu de personnes...
Effectivement, j'étais pas au courant.
En tout cas, bon, on l'a écrit dans le livre, en tout cas.
Je n'ai pas assez lu le livre.
Si, si, si, si. Donc c'était bien le cas. Alors, est-ce qu'il l'est toujours ? Ça, je sais pas. Depuis les élections, il a peut-être renoncé à la vie politique, mais en tout cas, il était directeur du mouvement,
en anglais, Movement, de Steve Bannon en Europe.
Et donc, à ce titre, Modrikamen avait pris son bâton de pèlerin et avait rencontré toute une série de personnalités ultra-radicales et d'extrême droite en Europe, Salvini, enfin d'autres personnes également.
Et pour la Belgique, apparemment, il avait tenté de convaincre le Vlaams Belang de rejoindre le mouvement et de s'associer.
Et ça s'est très mal passé. Et publiquement, le Vlaams Belang a traité, je sais pas ce qui s'est passé exactement, tu sais pas ce qui s'est passé exactement, mais a traité Michael Modrikamen de guignol, je crois.
C'était l'expression employée ou c'était assez similaire à ça.
Ils aiment bien les bouffons en Flandre.
Voilà, oui, décidément. Et donc ça s'était arrêté là. Et donc je crois que le Vlaams Belang n'avait pas voulu suivre Modrikamen sur ce plan-là.
Et puis finalement, ben l'histoire récente a donné raison au Vlaams Belang, puisque Modrikamen et le Parti populaire ont vraiment connu une débâcle, une débâcle aux élections, tout comme Alain Destexhe, sur une autre—
D'ailleurs, puisqu'on parle de l'extrême droite, est-ce que le PP est un parti d'extrême droite ?
Certains diront non.
Oui. Ça aussi, c'est pas clair parce qu'il y a certains politologues qui vont dire oui, d'autres diront non.
Je dirais à ce stade, sous réserve de preuves du contraire, ce n'est pas un parti d'extrême droite. Donc c'est plutôt un parti de droite populiste.
En tout cas, Modrikamen définit le PP comme un parti de droite populiste. Alors quelle est la frontière entre les deux ?
Ça, on peut en débattre pendant des heures. Mais moi, comme journaliste, en tout cas, et à La Libre, j'ai toujours pris le parti de considérer qu'il fallait interroger Michel Modrikamen et entendre ce qui est, voilà, et donner la parole à Modrikamen.
Énormément de choses à noter puisque là, tu évoques finalement la question du cordon sanitaire à laquelle on va revenir dans un instant.
Mais je voulais simplement réagir sur la notion de droite ferme populiste. Je pense qu'effectivement, sur les réseaux sociaux et dans leur façon de communiquer, on sent le côté un petit peu
shitpost du Parti Populaire quand ils retweetent des espèces de,
de gifs très, très douteux faits par des ados dans leur chambre.
C'est très... On retrouve un petit peu le côté 4chan, le côté un petit peu Donald Trump, comme ça. Donc,
c'est là-dessus qu'effectivement, je trouve personnellement, de mon point de vue, le Parti Populaire sent un petit peu les vieilles chaussettes.
Mais voilà. Mais donc, effectivement, un parti d'extrême droite, sans doute non. Et du coup, se pose la question : pourquoi est-ce que l'extrême droite a cartonné en Flandre et pas du tout en Belgique francophone ?
Il y a plusieurs explications et plusieurs explications contradictoires, mais il y a une explication que j'aime bien, qui me parle assez bien comme analyste, c'est une explication par l'offre politique.
Donc, je m'explique. En fait, en Belgique francophone, pour certaines raisons historiques, en particulier en Wallonie, le vote contestataire, depuis ces dernières années, se focalise sur l'extrême gauche.
Et en Flandre, pour d'autres raisons liées aussi à l'histoire, le vote contestataire s'exprime par l'extrême droite. C'est lié à l'offre politique.
Parce que l'histoire, en Wallonie, nous a amenés, l'histoire industrielle, par exemple, il n'y a pas que ça, mais c'est un élément, nous a amenés à avoir
un parti communiste qui survit et qui remonte dans les sondages et qui incarne une ligne contestataire.
Et en Flandre, pour d'autres raisons, mais c'est vraiment trop long, je peux pas rentrer là-dedans ici, pour des raisons historiques également, la contestation se fait par l'extrême droite.
On a pu effectivement entendre dans la bouche de certains électeurs, de Gand à Ostende, on peut-- même à Bruxelles, on a pu entendre certains électeurs qui ont voté Vlaams Belang dire :
moi, j'ai hésité entre voter Vlaams Belang et PVDA.
Oui.
Donc, ce qui caractériserait finalement ce vote comme étant, ouais, un vote contestataire.
En partie, oui. En partie. En partie, c'est vrai. Donc, il y a des gens qui voteront extrême droite parce que ce sont vraiment des extrémistes de droite et ils voteront jamais pour l'extrême gauche parce qu'ils les détestent.
Ça, c'est une partie du vote d'extrême droite. Mais il y a une partie, en effet,
de purs contestataires qui peuvent tout aussi bien voter pour l'extrême gauche comme pour l'extrême droite et qui vont hésiter avec l'un et l'autre en fonction de la qualité de l'offre politique du moment, du côté gauche ou du côté droit.
En fin avril, il y avait une interview tout à fait édifiante du Morgen, journal flamand plutôt de gauche, qui avait associé le président du PTB-PVDA, hein, PVDA, c'est le PTB.
Qui est donc, on peut le rappeler, le seul parti majeur qui soit présent à la fois en Belgique francophone et néerlandophone.
Il avait associé, en effet, Peter Mertens, président du PVDA-PTB, et Tom Van Grieken, président du Vlaams Belang. Et ces deux personnes avaient accepté de débattre dans le cadre d'une interview croisée organisée par le Morgen.
Et la phrase principale mise en exergue de cette interview, c'est : Vlaams Belang et PTB peuvent s'entendre lorsqu'il s'agit de contester l'establishment.
Donc là, je crois que cette interview est assez incroyable en fait. Ça veut dire qu'extrême gauche et extrême droite, qui doivent se détester sur certains aspects, pouvaient tout à fait s'entendre sur la ligne contestataire.
Oui, la ligne gilets jaunes, finalement.
Oui, alors ça, je veux pas réduire les gilets jaunes à des extrémistes. C'est plus compliqué que ça. Je voudrais certainement pas faire partie des-
Quand je parle de ligne gilets jaunes, je ne veux pas parler de la ligne extrémiste, que ce soit extrême droite ou extrême gauche, mais je parle de l'aspect contestataire, quoi, l'aspect anti-système, anti-establishment.
Oui.
C'est, oui ?
Voilà, mais avec toutes les précautions, parce que je voudrais pas faire passer pour-- je fais pas partie des gens qui,
comme on a vu au début du mouvement, en France notamment, en particulier, qui ont fait passer les gilets jaunes pour des espèces de beaufs qui ne comprenaient rien à rien.
Je crois que la contestation des gilets jaunes est plus complexe que ça et moins-
C'était pas ce que je disais non plus.
Voilà, non, je sais. Je dis ça de manière générale, pas par rapport à tes propos. Mais il faut pas assimiler les gilets jaunes ni à l'extrême gauche ni à l'extrême droite.
Ce serait une erreur, même s'il y a une contestation de quelque chose. Mais c'est pas pour ça qu'on devient extrémiste.
De par leur contestation, il y a quand même un mouvement qui tend vers les extrêmes, je pense, de manière générale.
C'est un mouvement qui s'est exprimé parfois de manière violente, mais ce n'est pas pour ça qu'il faudrait les catégoriser d'extrême gauche ou d'extrême droite.
Je regarde, il y avait un peu de-- il y avait tout le monde dans ce mouvement-là. Il y a des mères de famille qui ne s'en sortent pas, voilà, qui ne sont pas d'extrême droite pour autant.
Donc, je crois qu'il faut vraiment pas-
J'associe quand même très fort le mouvement des gilets jaunes avec un certain anticapitalisme, un certain antilibéralisme, un certain, voilà.
Je sais pas hein. Moi, je sais pas, non.
C'est compliqué ?
Voilà, je crois qu'il y a certainement des gens comme ça dedans. Il y a cette-- ce sont des mouvements qui sont hyper hétérogènes.
C'est hyper hétérogène, difficile de catégoriser, évidemment, sans se tromper. Il y a de tout. Mais alors, finalement, que veulent-ils, ces gens ?
Ils veulent, je pense, ils voulaient pouvoir simplement vivre dignement dans une société, oui, capitaliste et une société de consommation.
Et leur revenu ne leur permet manifestement pas de couvrir les frais de fonctionnement de base, quoi. L'essence, les courses au supermarché, ce genre de choses-là.
Et donc, ils ne s'en sortent pas et c'est un cri de colère, quoi. Mais la Révolution française, c'est lié directement au prix du pain.
C'est pas lié, directement, le peuple ne fait pas la révolution parce qu'il a trop lu Rousseau. Il fait la révolution parce que le prix du pain est devenu ingérable et donc c'est insupportable et on fait la révolution.
Donc voilà, ce que je veux dire, c'est qu'un mouvement contestataire qui part de problèmes du quotidien, de survie à court terme, de paiement des factures, peut faire l'histoire aussi.
Donc je balayerai jamais d'un-- je veux pas balayer d'un revers de la main
le mouvement des Gilets jaunes. Comme-- mais parce qu'on l'a vu au début, je dis pas, ce n'est pas ton cas, mais, au début, il y avait des éditos méprisants d'une certaine presse française.
Certainement, et parisienne, ouais.
Mais ça, c'était vraiment une énorme erreur, une énorme erreur. Mais ça, voilà, je dis ça à titre personnel.
Ça n'a fait-- oui, non, mais c'est assez proche de ce que disait Alain Gerlache dans ce même podcast il y a quelques mois, hein, c'est...
Après, ben, et d'ailleurs, on a vu au sein du mouvement Gilets jaunes, il y a des sorties contre la presse où on...
une haine pour le journalisme, pour les journalistes qui émane sans doute effectivement d'un certain mépris, une certaine récurrence des mêmes visages qui reviennent tout le temps et qui sont en décalage avec la réalité qu'eux connaissent.
Donc effectivement, tout ça est assez cohérent. Mais donc finalement, pour moi, je lis les analyses de ce résultat électoral ici en Belgique.
On l'entend souvent : « Tiens, il y aurait deux démocraties, au nord, on vote à l'extrême droite, au sud, on vote à l'extrême gauche.
» Mais sur base de la conversation qu'on a ici maintenant, moi, je me dis : mais en fait, ce vote, c'est le même vote.
C'est-- enfin, c'est plus compliqué, évidemment, mais c'est en partie, en grande partie, le même vote, c'est-à-dire un vote contestataire, un vote antisystème qui,
au sud, se concrétise par un vote d'extrême gauche, au nord par un vote d'extrême droite.
Mais est-ce que ce n'est pas finalement le même phénomène ?
Alors, je voudrais répondre-- j'aurais envie de répondre que oui, mais en fait, non.
Non, OK.
Je vais faire une réponse complexe parce que-
C'est très bien
...je crois que c'est complexe. C'est d'un côté, oui, c'est vrai. D'un côté, il y a des mécanismes communs au vote contestataire.
En partie, oui.
Oui, il y a un mécanisme commun qui amène au vote contestataire et en partie non. En partie, c'est faux parce que, qu'on le veuille ou pas, qu'on soit nationaliste ou pas, qu'on soit Belge ou pas,
Bart De Wever, lorsqu'il dit qu'il y a deux démocraties dans ce pays, n'a pas complètement tort parce qu'on vit dans deux univers flamands et francophones. On vit-
Il y a deux cultures très clairement, ça, c'est sûr.
On vit dans deux univers séparés, en grande partie. On a notre propre univers médiatique. Combien de personnes le soir regardent le JT de la VRT ?
Combien de francophones regardent le JT de la VRT ? Combien de francophones connaissent les émissions politiques flamandes ?
Combien de francophones connaissent les Bekende Vlamingen ? Les personnalités-
Oui, bien sûr
...les personnalités flamandes du showbiz.
On en a beaucoup parlé avec Rudy Lionel, des Bekende Vlamingen.
À l'inverse, combien de Flamands connaissent les personnalités typiquement francophones ? Mais quasiment aucun.
Mais à ce moment-là, cette réponse, on peut la pousser à l'extrême et dire : mais à ce moment-là, il n'y a pas que deux démocraties, la démocratie belge néerlandophone et la, la démocratie belge francophone.
On peut dire : mais il y en a 15, il y en a 10, puisque effectivement, il y a
les Belges francophones qui habitent à Liège et qui lisent tel média, qui sont dans tel pilier, qui regardent la RTBF.
Et puis, il y a les Belges francophones qui habitent à Haut-lieu-Saint-Pierre et qui consomment d'autres médias, qui consomment une autre culture et qui...
Donc, est-ce qu'il y en a deux ou est-ce qu'il y en a dix, des démocraties en Belgique ?
Très, très bonne question. En effet, on pourrait pousser la logique à l'infini et ne jamais s'en sortir, parce qu'il y a toujours tellement d'occasions de diviser les gens en groupes et en sous-groupes.
Donc ça, c'est vraiment la chose la plus facile du monde, c'est diviser les-- trouver des occasions de se diviser.
Mais reste quand même que la remarque n'est pas folle. C'est que même si à Liège et à Tournai, on peut avoir une réalité locale différente et chacun être fier de sa propre ville, on partage quand même la même langue.
On partage quand même une même culture. On a lu les mêmes auteurs. Bien souvent, le JT de la RTBF est le même pour tous.
Les pages nationales de La Libre, qu'on soit à Tournai ou à Liège, sont les mêmes. Donc, il y a quand même une culture commune quoi, hein, voilà.
Oui, c'est sûr que-
Et donc le fossé est quand même plutôt nord-sud, en l'occurrence. Maintenant, ça ne veut pas dire qu'on aurait raison, forcément, de se séparer.
C'est pas ça que je veux dire. C'est pas pour ça qu'il faut faire éclater le pays. À ce moment-là, on peut faire éclater l'Union européenne aussi.
Parce que l'Union européenne aussi, c'est une juxtaposition de démocraties qui ne se connaissent pas, mais qui pourtant ont un intérêt supérieur à se rassembler.
Donc peut-être que la même logique,
qui pousse l'Union européenne, malgré de grandes difficultés, à se rassembler,
à rassembler des démocraties très différentes avec des langues différentes et des cultures hyper différentes, des réalités hyper différentes, peut-être qu'on peut faire la même chose en Belgique
et que la solution la plus simple, ce serait de tout faire éclater.
Quoique avec le Brexit, je pense que quelques personnes au nord et en Flandre pourraient réfléchir davantage aux conséquences qu'aurait la sortie de la Flandre de la Belgique.
Ce serait quand même très compliqué, je pense. Donc voilà, c'est pas pour ça qu'il faut faire exploser le pays. On peut très bien décider de,
de se donner une véritable, un véritable avenir avec-- en considérant qu'en effet, il y a deux démocraties différentes, mais que c'est pas pour ça qu'on doit les gouverner de manière différente.
Ça, c'est la thèse de la N-VA. Il faut les gouverner de manière différente. Et puis la thèse d'autres personnes qui sont refédéralistes comme Alexander De Croo ou Groen ou les Jeunes MR, ce sont des gens qui sont refédéralistes.
Je dois dire que moi, j'aimais beaucoup, là, on part complètement hors sujet, mais j'aimais beaucoup le,
le point de vue de monsieur Philippe Van Parijs dans cette même émission et dans son livre, voilà, qui est donc un universitaire très connu ici en Belgique,
qui défend l'idée que ben, finalement, et c'est vrai que moi, en tant que jeune Belge, je me reconnais très fort là-dedans,
ben entre Belges, on se parle de plus en plus anglais en fait.
Donc moi, de manière professionnelle, dans les médias, quand je rencontre un Flamand, et cetera, tout ça, majoritairement, j'emploie l'anglais.
Donc, la grande question, enfin, peut-être que je suis le seul à me la poser, mais c'est : est-ce que le fossé qui nous sépare entre Belges francophones et Belges néerlandophones ne va pas petit à petit se réparer à coup d'échanges
Anglophone.
Donc c'est exactement la thèse de Philippe Van Parijs, en effet. Donc lui dit que à terme, la langue la mieux parlée par les différents groupes en Belgique finira par s'imposer.
Donc c'est l'anglais hein.
Les francophones parleront mieux l'anglais que le néerlandais et les néerlandophones parleront mieux l'anglais que le français.
Exactement. Et ce sera la langue, d'après lui, la plus facile à parler puisqu'elle est relativement facile à apprendre pour un francophone et très facile à apprendre pour un néerlandophone.
Donc ce serait l'idée. Alors, je l'avais soumise, j'avais soumis cette idée à plusieurs personnes, plusieurs personnalités politiques.
Oui. Et c'est pas l'engouement hein, je dois le dire. C'est pas pour ça que ça va pas arriver à long terme. Ça pourrait arriver à très long terme, mais à court terme, y aura pas d'initiative politique pour aller en ce sens.
J'avais posé la question à, par exemple, Jan Jambon.
D'accord.
Hein, qui avait dit : « Jamais... »
Ça l'intéresse pas forcément.
Ça l'intéressait pas beaucoup. Donc il disait-
Politiquement, c'est contre son projet hein Voilà, Philippe Van Parijs, c'est un universitaire qui fait des raisonnements dans sa tour d'ivoire et qui ne connaît pas la réalité.
Donc ça, c'était un peu la réponse de Jambon. Mais j'ai posé la question aussi à Christophe Calvo, de Groen.
Ouais.
Qui lui est un refédéraliste, limite pro-belgiquin.
lui disait qu'il n'y croyait pas non plus. Lui, il disait : « Je préfère qu'on applique la solution qu'on pratique chez nous, dans notre groupe à la Chambre des représentants Écolo-Groen » hein, puisqu'ils ont-
Ouais.
Ils ont un seul groupe à deux, francophones et flamands. Chacun parle sa langue, en fait. Chacun parle-- le plus facile, c'est de parler sa langue, en fait, sa propre langue maternelle.
C'est presque, c'est un peu la même vision que, je sais pas si tu as posé la question à Alexander De Croo, mais il est aussi un petit peu, euh...
C'est presque une espèce de décalage hein de mon point de vue, de dire : « Ben oui, les Wallons vont parler flamand et les Flamands vont parler français ».
Ben dans les faits, c'est pas trop ce qu'on constate.
Non.
C'est un peu idéaliste.
Voilà, ça, c'est peut-être un peu idéaliste parce que la réalité, et ça, c'est Van Parijs, Philippe Van Parijs a raison, c'est qu'il y a toujours une langue qui finit par l'emporter dans les échanges.
Donc pour le moment, en Belgique, le français est mieux connu par les Flamands que les francophones ne connaissent le néerlandais.
Donc c'est le français qui finit en général par s'imposer dans les échanges. C'est la langue la mieux connue par les deux qui finit par s'imposer.
Donc, croire que...
Est-ce que ce n'est pas déjà l'anglais, d'ailleurs ?
Tout le monde sera bilingue des deux côtés, mais alors quelle langue est-ce qu'on choisit dans nos échanges ? Ça n'ira pas.
Il y a toujours une langue qui finit par dominer. Et donc il y a toujours-
Actuellement, c'est le français, ouais.
Il y a toujours une frustration qui en résulte. Et donc, Philippe Van Parijs disait : « Mais prenons une langue tierce » et qui est la langue parfaite pour ça, c'est l'anglais, évidemment.
Mais ça, voilà, ça, c'est un... Mais il dit dans son analyse : « Ça finira par s'imposer naturellement, de manière chaotique, de manière erratique, par tous ces contacts.
» Voilà, ça finira par venir. D'ailleurs, je pense que dans certaines marches pour le climat, entre jeunes néerlandophones et jeunes francophones qui marchaient pour le climat, je crois que l'anglais a été quelquefois la langue utilisée.
Ouais, moi, je veux dire hein, de mon expérience, ma Belgique à moi, c'est déjà celle-là hein. Je parle déjà exclusivement anglais avec les néerlandophones. Donc
je vois ça comme une évidence, moi, mais peut-être que, je sais pas. Toi, à titre personnel, si on quitte
la prudence et les analyses du niveau de politique, c'est une analyse que tu partages ou est-ce que tu es sceptique, toi aussi, vis-à-vis de ça ?
En tout cas, si on utilisait l'anglais dans ce pays comme langue commune, je dirais d'Ostende à Arlon, comme langue pour parler avec les personnes de l'autre communauté linguistique, ce serait assez révolutionnaire.
Ça changerait complètement-
Ouais, ce serait du jamais vu, ouais.
Ce serait du jamais vu. Donc ce serait de nature à changer radicalement les rapports entre les gens dans ce pays et à faire sauter le verrou des deux démocraties.
Puisque là, imaginons qu'on ait des médias communs en langue anglaise, on aurait des médias belges, regarder-- enfin une partie des médias seraient des médias nationaux belges, en anglais, regardés d'Ostende à Arlon, d'Anvers à Arlon.
Donc ce serait tout à fait révolutionnaire. Donc, mais là, je pense que pour arriver à ça, il faudrait une volonté politique.
Politique, bien sûr.
Je crois qu'elle n'est absolument pas là aujourd'hui.
Aujourd'hui. Donc si ça arrive, ça prendra quelques générations.
Voilà, que ça finisse par s'imposer naturellement parce que l'anglais est en train de s'imposer naturellement et ça prendra encore quelques décennies.
Et puis est-ce que les médias aujourd'hui, ce ne sont pas majoritairement les réseaux sociaux et les médias, euh...
Est-ce que c'est toujours top down ou est-ce que ce serait plutôt bottom up, les médias aujourd'hui ?
Voilà, c'est ça. En effet, avec l'explosion des réseaux sociaux et tous ces podcasts et tous ces blogueurs. Bon voilà, la réalité viendra aussi.
J'ai interviewé Alexander De Croo en anglais, pour l'anecdote. Donc...
Voilà, voilà. Mais il parle très très bien anglais. Donc voilà, cette logique-là, elle peut venir d'en bas hein.
Tout à fait, je suis bien d'accord, oui.
C'est ça. Toujours sur cette logique de Belgique refédéralisée, plus unie qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui.
Alexander De Croo parlait dans un entretien avec toi il y a quelques mois, il y a près d'un an, je pense, de l'idée d'une circonscription fédérale.
C'est également une idée que défend régulièrement Ecolo-Groen. Un article qui n'a pas été ouvert à la révision pour cette législature-ci.
Alors, c'est peut-être une question terriblement, terriblement pénible et inintéressante, mais
en tant qu'analyste politique, est-ce que tu penses que ça va arriver un jour ou est-ce que les partis politiques le bloqueront inévitablement ?
Alors, comme analyste politique, je crois que la logique de ce pays nous pousse à... C'est une logique centrifuge.
Donc les institutions centrales finissent par se faire éjecter vers les entités régionales.
On part plus vers le confédéralisme que vers la refédéralisation, que vers le...
On va vers plus de régionalisation, ça, c'est certain. Enfin, j'en suis persuadé. La refédéralisation... En fait, ce qu'on appelle le confédéralisme n'a pas de majorité.
De définition, oui, surtout.
En fait, la définition n'est pas la bonne, mais sans rentrer dans les détails. Quand on parle de confédéralisme, en fait, ça veut rien dire du tout hein.
Donc il faut juste parler d'une... Si, y a une définition, mais elle n'est pas du tout celle de la N-VA, donc qui utilise un terme qui ne veut rien dire en fait dans sa bouche.
En fait, la N-VA parle d'une régionalisation poussée à l'extrême. On garderait un État fédéral, en fait. Donc c'est très particulier. Donc la logique de la Belgique est d'aller vers plus de régionalisation.
Alors, une régionalisation totale radicale n'a pas de majorité aujourd'hui dans les partis, mais une refédéralisation n'aura pas plus de majorité non plus demain.
Et donc, ce statu quo me laisse penser qu'on va simplement continuer à glisser sur cette pente,
sur laquelle je ne porte pas de jugement, cette pente qui emmène le délitement progressif de l'État fédéral vers les entités régionales.
Donc les régions vont prendre de plus en plus de poids dans ce pays. Alors peut-être qu'un jour, on arrivera à un équilibre et que ça ne changera plus.
En tout cas, ici, il est certain qu'il faudra une septième réforme de l'État, ne serait-ce que pour corriger les problèmes de la sixième.
Mais la logique du pays est une logique centrifuge qui va vers plus de régionalisation. Et j'ai quand même l'impression que c'est vers cela qu'on ira, parce que c'est la voie la plus facile, je dirais, pour le monde politique.
Pour refédéraliser des compétences, ça demanderait une volonté politique hors norme.
Pour les compétences, pour les ministères, ça, je partage tout à fait l'analyse. Maintenant, ce qui est intéressant, c'est que tu vois, tu as fait un glissement entre
le système électoral, la circonscription fédérale, le fait de pouvoir voter pour Theo Francken quand on habite à Arlon ou pour Charles Michel quand on habite à Ostende.
Je posais une question sur les circonscriptions et tu as shifté sur le système de compétences. Pour toi, il y a un rapport direct entre les deux.
C'est si on régionalise l'un, on régionalise forcément l'autre. C'est pas compatible l'idée de faire une circonscription fédérale et un...
Ben voilà. Mais donc, pourquoi est-ce que tu fais ce glissement, alors ?
Ben parce qu'on parlait de l'avenir du pays et l'avenir du pays est plutôt une logique de la régionalisation.
D'accord, ouais.
Je parlais plutôt de ça. Mais c'est vrai qu'on pourrait en même temps imaginer une circonscription fédérale.
Est-ce que tu vois ça arriver ? Est-ce que ça te paraît imaginable dans la Belgique, dans le climat actuel, dans le climat...
Ben tout est... Bon allez, en Belgique, tout est possible. Voilà, soyons clairs. Qui serais-je pour dire que c'est impossible ?
Non, c'est possible. Mais je dis que ce n'est pas forcément probable.
Ce n'est pas probable, d'après toi ?
Ça va être compliqué.
Ouais.
Parce que je crois que voilà, il y a rien à faire. Le plus grand parti en Flandre est quand même un parti nationaliste dont le but n'est pas de refédéraliser ni de recréer des circonscriptions électorales fédérales.
Oui, mais si on prend tous les partis wallons, plus une minorité en Flandre, plus tous les partis bruxellois...
Oui, oui, mais est-ce que les partis francophones sont si fans ?
C'est toute la question. C'est toute la question que je pose.
On peut se poser la question parce que...
Quel désavantage pour les élus wallons d'avoir une circonscription fédérale ?
Ben déjà quand les élus wallons, qui ne sont pas forcément tous bilingues, devront aller faire campagne
à Poperinge ou dans la banlieue bruxelloise, ça va être vachement compliqué pour s'expliquer en patois local ou en néerlandais, même en bon néerlandais, en tussentaal, comme on dit aujourd'hui.
Oui, c'est pour ça que ça bénéficiera sans doute effectivement plutôt aux, voilà, donc aux Ecolo-Groen qui sont, disons, dit-on, plus diplômés, plus bilingues que peut-être les socialistes wallons.
Donc, il y a effectivement peut-être une logique électorale.
Ben ça, de manière générale, ça profiterait, j'imagine, plus aux mandataires néerlandophones qui sont quand même aujourd'hui, malgré tout...
Mais parmi les francophones
...meilleurs bilingues. Et parmi les francophones, la norme n'est pas au bilinguisme, hein.
C'est ça.
Et je ne...
Sauf chez Ecolo-Groen, pour le coup, puisqu'il y a...
Je sais pas si chez Ecolo, tout le monde est bilingue, ça, je n'en sais rien.
Mais tu disais au sein du groupe parlementaire à la Chambre, chacun parle français.
Oui, mais c'est la règle, mais c'est pas pour ça que j'ai été vérifier que chaque député Ecolo francophone...
Parce qu'en fait, ils ne se comprennent pas quand ils se parlent.
Ce que l'autre communauté linguistique explique. J'imagine que oui, bien sûr. Mais voilà, il suffit pas de décréter ou de dire qu'on fait quelque chose pour que ce soit la réalité.
Voilà. Donc ça, c'était la petite parenthèse absolument imprévue sur la refédéralisation et sur l'anglais en Belgique.
On va revenir un petit peu sur les résultats de l'extrême droite. Donc, tu l'as évoqué avec Steve Bannon et son mouvement, il y a quelques dizaines de minutes.
On voit effectivement une tendance à l'échelle européenne, monter des extrêmes un peu partout, hein. Chez le Rassemblement national en France qui est arrivé premier aux élections européennes.
Un léger chaos politique en Italie, mais malgré tout, voilà, les premiers partis restent des partis d'extrêmes.
UKIP au Royaume-Uni. Bref, on voit ça un petit peu partout. Alors ça, c'est
un petit peu ma conviction à moi et peut-être que tu ne la partageras pas du tout, mais on sait qu'il y a dans le bureau de Philippe Dewinter trois drapeaux, et
j'ai lu ça dans un article dans La Libre Belgique, mais trois drapeaux qui siègent sur sa cheminée
: le drapeau de l'Union européenne, le drapeau de la Russie et le drapeau du parti de Vladimir Poutine.
Ce qu'il n'y a pas eu, et ce qu'il n'y a pas pu avoir, est-ce qu'on soupçonne qu'il y ait pu y avoir l'ombre de Vladimir Poutine sur les résultats de nos élections ?
Alors moi, je ne suis pas agent secret, mais en tout cas, c'est une des questions qui ont été posées. Apparemment, en tout cas, la Russie n'est pas intervenue dans le processus ici en Belgique.
D'après les premiers éléments que j'ai pu lire, en tout cas, les premières analyses de la Sûreté de l'État.
La Sûreté de l'État, oui.
Voilà. Maintenant, voilà, je peux pas m'avancer là-dessus, je n'ai aucun élément par rapport à ça, donc je n'oserais pas affirmer quoi que ce soit.
Maintenant, qu'il y ait eu des tentatives, est-ce que c'est des tentatives du gouvernement russe officiel via des hackers qui travaillent pour son compte ou bien des initiatives d'autres personnes proches du pouvoir en Russie ?
Je pense qu'il y a suffisamment de doutes...
Alors, en l'occurrence, je ne parlais pas de... parce que bon, effectivement, on sait qu'il y a eu dans le rapport de Special Counsel, Special Counsel Robert Mueller, aux USA, qui révélait qu'effectivement, il y a eu
des injections SQL, pour ceux qui savent ce que ça veut dire, des injections SQL sur certaines machines de vote aux États-Unis.
Donc bon, ça, c'est pour l'aspect technique, l'aspect vraiment piratage de machines de vote qui est très grave, mais je ne pensais pas tellement à ça. Je pensais plutôt,
on sait qu'il y a une unité spéciale qui a été créée par la Commission européenne sur demande d'une série de chefs d'État européens, pour lutter contre ce qu'on appelle les campagnes de désinformation du Kremlin. Et on sait que justement,
les chiffres qui sont sortis pour montrer que
il y avait quoi, plus de sept cent mille euros de campagne Facebook qui avait été dépensée par le Vlaams Belang,
bon pour des campagnes qui sont, voilà, à caractère très cru, très extrême, mais sans jamais dépasser les conditions d'utilisation de Facebook.
Donc là, effectivement, de nouveau, c'est mon analyse à deux balles, mon soupçon dit : mais on retrouve un petit peu le côté Kremlin derrière tout ça.
Oui, bon ça, je peux certainement pas m'avancer par rapport à ça. On n'a aucun élément...
Non, mais je parle de soupçon. Je parle de... Est-ce qu'on se pose la question ou bien est-ce qu'on s'interroge ?
Je vais répondre à côté, parce qu'on peut rien affirmer, évidemment, par rapport à ça.
Je ne demande pas d'affirmer, ouais.
En étant un tout petit peu sérieux, mais voilà. En étant un tout petit peu sérieux. Par contre, ce qu'on peut analyser, mais alors là, on sort un peu de la Belgique, c'est que la Russie a un intérêt, peut avoir un intérêt
à avoir une Europe divisée.
Mh.
Mais les États-Unis ont le même intérêt, hein. Il me semble que Donald Trump, en excitant l'instinct,
l'instinct britannique par rapport à une sortie, via Brexit dur, comme il est en train de le faire pour le moment, à Buckingham pour le moment, c'est ça.
C'est créer une forme de chaos en Europe pour pouvoir mieux imposer ses propres règles dans la redéfinition des règles des échanges mondiaux que lui a entrepris.
Mais la Russie peut avoir également un intérêt à affaiblir l'Europe, ne serait-ce que pour avoir plus de poids, ou plus d'influence dans ses anciens pays satellites d'Europe de l'Ouest.
Ça, c'est pour le motif. Voilà, on se dirait : tiens, ce serait le jeu.
Ça a un intérêt géostratégique. Voilà. Ça, c'est clair.
Au-delà de ça, on peut effectivement, comme tu disais, rien affirmer. Maintenant, la question se pose
: cet argent, ce prêt de millions d'euros de campagne dépensée sur Facebook pour un parti qui, de 2014 à 2019, avait finalement relativement peu d'élus.
La question que j'ai envie de poser, c'est : mais d'où sort cet argent ?
Alors ça, moi, j'ai pas enquêté là-dessus, donc je serais incapable de...
Est-ce que c'est normal, pour un parti politique belge flamand avec aussi peu d'élus, d'avoir dans ses poches près d'un million d'euros ?
Ça, j'en sais rien. Maintenant, quelles sont leurs sources de financement ? Maintenant, il y a des règles de financement des partis politiques en Belgique.
S'ils ne les ont pas respectées, j'imagine que cela intéressera la justice. Je n'ai aucun élément par rapport à ça. Donc, je peux rien affirmer.
Ce que je sais en tout cas, c'est que le Vlaams Belang a notamment réussi sa campagne électorale et a gagné aux élections
en utilisant à fond, en effet, les réseaux sociaux et en investissant beaucoup d'argent là-dedans, ce qui lui a permis de ramener pas mal de jeunes,
dans ses nouveaux électeurs.
Voilà, ça, je peux l'affirmer.
Tu n'as pas un ordre d'idée de savoir quels sont les moyens habituels pour un parti politique comme le Vlaams Belang ?
Tu ne sais pas dire si un million, c'est beaucoup, si c'est très peu, si c'est...
Non, c'est dans l'ordre de grandeur habituel, je pense. Mais à nouveau, je voudrais pas que ma réponse induise quoi que ce soit.
Non, c'est ça, OK.
Ce n'est pas... Je veux absolument rien induire. Ça fait partie des budgets, bon le Vlaams Belang est un parti ancien.
La fois dernière, il n'a pas vraiment cartonné, mais par le passé, ils ont pesé beaucoup plus lourd que ce qu'ils ne pèsent maintenant.
Il faut jamais l'oublier non plus, en 2004, la victoire était tout autre que maintenant. Elle était beaucoup plus forte, encore.
Et donc le parti a peut-être des moyens, mais j'avoue que j'ai pas enquêté sur les finances du Vlaams Belang, donc je peux rien affirmer.
Je serais vraiment mal à l'aise de dire quoi que ce soit par rapport à ça.
J'ai bien compris. On va, je vais pas insister plus que ça là-dessus, mais,
est-ce que c'est une question qui t'intéresse pour éventuellement une enquête ultérieure, de s'interroger sur la source de ce financement ou bien est-ce que tu vas plutôt...
Ça, c'est bien le job des journalistes politiques d'enquêter sur le financement des partis. Oui, bien sûr.
Ouais, OK. Tu vas y songer.
Ben je vais y songer sans induire que je considère qu'il y a des soupçons par rapport à la campagne.
Sans idées, sans a priori. Un mot alors à présent sur l'avenir du pays. Selon la personne à qui on demande, on parle d'éventuellement une période de négociations qui va de nouveau durer ad vitam æternam cinq cent quarante jours.
De nouveau, une question terriblement naïve, terriblement simple, mais quelle est ton analyse ? Est-ce que d'après toi, on est reparti pour cinq cent quarante jours ou bien est-ce qu'
on va pouvoir voir apparaître une solution magique ?
Certains parlent de la coalition bourguignonne qui, pour le coup, serait vraiment une solution magique très, très inattendue.
Qu'est-ce que tu anticipes ? Quelles sont les possibilités qui, d'après toi, sont les plus crédibles ?
Alors, ben la possibilité... Bon. Donc il y a une première piste, c'est qu'il y a une grosse crise politique parce que les entités fédérées, donc les régions hein,
pourront avoir des coalitions relativement rapidement et relativement facilement,
que ce soit en Flandre, à la Région wallonne, à la Région Bruxelles-Capitale, et à la Communauté française.
La Communauté germanophone a déjà son nouveau gouvernement. Par contre, pour le fédéral, ça va être très compliqué parce qu'il va falloir faire cohabiter, on en parlait, deux démocraties.
Il va falloir faire cohabiter le choix des Flamands avec le choix des francophones pour gouverner les matières fédérales.
Le choix des francophones fait que le PS est premier. Le choix des Flamands fait que la N-VA est première. La N-VA a dit qu'elle ne gouvernerait pas avec le PS.
Le PS a dit qu'il ne gouvernerait pas avec la N-VA. Alors, ça va être très compliqué. Donc a priori, arithmétiquement et politiquement, c'est très compliqué.
Le Vlaams Belang a cartonné, le PTB a cartonné. Ce sont des partis, a priori, qu'on ne peut pas associer au pouvoir fédéral.
Donc, ce sont autant de sièges de perdus pour former une future majorité. Donc les partis qui restent doivent s'entendre entre eux pour former quelque part une majorité, malgré toutes les exclusives qu'ils ont envoyées les uns vis-à-vis des autres.
Donc, la possibilité, c'est que soit il y a une crise politique qui s'éternise, qui pourrait aboutir à des élections anticipées, ce qui serait, à mon avis, désastreux parce que ça ne ferait que renforcer les extrêmes.
Ça compliquerait encore plus la situation. Ça, c'est mon avis. Ou alors, une possibilité qui est dans les têtes, qui est un scénario idéal, c'est que PS et N-VA arrivent à se réconcilier pour une législature
à gouverner ensemble aux côtés des libéraux, donc les libéraux flamands et les libéraux francophones, les socialistes flamands, les socialistes francophones plus la N-VA.
Ça ferait donc ce qu'on appelle la coalition bourguignonne, qui en fait fait référence aux armes, aux armoiries de l'ancien duché de Bourgogne, qui était jaune, rouge et...
où on retrouvait les couleurs jaune, rouge et bleu, donc jaune pour la N-VA, bleu pour les libéraux et rouge pour les socialistes.
Et donc cette coalition aurait l'avantage d'avoir la majorité à la Chambre des représentants et une majorité simple dans les deux groupes linguistiques.
Ce qui est, ça, c'est les détails institutionnels, mais c'était un gros souci pour la N-VA. Alors, en échange
de l'effort que la N-VA ferait en acceptant de gouverner au fédéral avec le PS, on lancerait une grande réflexion pour une nouvelle réforme de l'État après 2024.
Et donc la N-VA pourrait sauver la face en obtenant cela. Et les socialistes pourraient éventuellement être d'accord de gouverner avec la N-VA parce que l'on pense que
vu la percée du Vlaams Belang en Flandre,
la N-VA va devoir adopter un style un peu plus social parce qu'elle s'est rendu compte, on en a parlé aussi, que le vote extrême droite en Flandre était lié aussi à des questions sociales et qu'elle était peut-être allée un peu loin
sur les questions de pension, les questions de salaire minimum et que peut-être les Flamands étaient plus inquiets qu'elle ne le pensait par rapport à leur avenir socioéconomique.
Et peut-être après plusieurs semaines ou plusieurs mois de discussions, ça va prendre très longtemps, peut-être, on aura cette coalition bourguignonne, qui est calquée en fait sur l'alliance qui existe aujourd'hui à Anvers.
Tu as de nombreux contacts au sein du Parti socialiste. Est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui convainc ou est-ce que quand tu interroges, on te répond : « Jamais de la vie, non, impossible. »
Ben non, je crois que les socialistes sont, c'est un parti qui est assez gestionnaire, hein. Donc c'est un parti qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime pas, c'est un parti qui a la tête sur les épaules.
Et donc, au-delà des déclarations...
Il faut des exclusions en public, pourtant.
Oui, mais ça, c'est la posture qu'on a pendant la campagne, qu'un parti a pendant une campagne électorale, elle est quasiment oubliée dès le matin, le lendemain matin qui suit les élections.
Ça, c'est la règle. Alors, les exclusives qui ont été lancées, mais elles sont là pour être levées.
Alors, les socialistes en off, bon, ne raffolent pas de la NVA, ça, c'est clair, hein, mais c'est surtout le problème socioéconomique qui les dérange.
Parce qu'en fait, le PS, à la base, c'est plutôt un parti régionaliste,
même si c'est pas affiché ouvertement. Si vous demandez à un PS wallon s'il a envie d'avoir plus de compétences qui seraient gérées depuis Namur plutôt que depuis Bruxelles, il va signer demain.
Hein, le régionalisme wallon est lié à l'histoire du PS. Donc, on peut imaginer que sur le plan institutionnel, NVA et PS pourraient s'entendre, même si le PS ne va pas le claironner.
Mais ce qui peut coincer, c'est l'aspect socioéconomique. Alors, est-ce que la NVA acceptera ? Mais là, on est vraiment dans la politique fiction totale.
Oui, c'est ça, c'est du fantasme. Est-ce que-
Non, c'est pas du fantasme, c'est un scénario de sortie de crise.
Oui, fantasmer.
Non, pas fantasmer, parce que fantasmer, ça voudrait dire que ce serait irréaliste.
Ça voudrait dire qu'on l'a inventé, nous, journalistes, et finalement-
Non, ce n'est pas les journalistes qui l'ont inventé. C'est le scénario qui tourne dans certaines têtes au plus haut niveau de la politique actuellement.
Ce n'est pas une invention journalistique.
Et donc, tu entends, enfin, de la part de certaines têtes. Ce que j'essaie de savoir, en fait, c'est est-ce qu'il faut accorder du crédit à cette théorie ou bien est-ce que c'est encore trop imaginé, trop-
Oui, alors ça, c'est clair que c'est une piste et que pour le moment, on n'y est pas du tout. Ça, c'est évident. Et si on devait y arriver, ce qui reste tout à fait hypothétique, en effet,
ça prendra des semaines et des mois de négociations parce que ça va être très très difficile de faire admettre au PS et à la NVA de gouverner ensemble.
Mais le problème, c'est qu'il n'y a pas vraiment d'autres solutions aujourd'hui. Soit on fait ça, soit il faut un gouvernement à huit.
Un gouvernement à huit avec tous les-
Oui, c'est ça avec le-
Avec tout le monde. Tout le monde sauf la NVA. Je vais les citer, donc Roose, Ecolo, Open VLD-
Tout le monde sauf le NVA et le PTB.
Oui voilà, c'est ça. Et ni le PTB.
Voilà. Oui, oui, forcément, oui.
Donc pas les extrêmes et pas la NVA. À ce moment-là, il faut gouverner à huit ou à sept. Bon, disons à huit en gros, hein.
Ou à sept. Mais alors ça, c'est un gouvernement, mais-
Inimaginable.
Qui est absolument, qui est imaginable arithmétiquement, mais qui sera un gouvernement pour ne pas gouverner. Parce qu'il faudra-
Est-ce que ça ne favoriserait pas justement les extrêmes qui-
Ben complètement.
Oui, parce que c'est un gouvernement qui serait improductif.
Voilà.
Et qui, du coup, tendrait à favoriser les adversaires.
En tout cas, ce ne sera pas forcément le gouvernement le plus pratique et le plus maniable du monde. Et alors, je me mets à la place des partis flamands, donc par exemple, au hasard, l'Open VLD,
qui ferait partie de ce gouvernement à huit ou à sept.
Qui aurait-il dans l'opposition en Flandre pour l'attaquer tous les jours ? La NVA, le Vlaams Belang et le PTB-PVDA.
Oui, donc une partie de son propre électorat, peut-être.
Ben oui, mais surtout trois partis féroces quoi.
Ouais, c'est ça, oui.
Trois partis, mais qui vont massacrer l'Open VLD.
Hm.
La NVA face à l'Open VLD, qui aurait accepté un gouvernement à huit juste pour faire un gouvernement et...
Ce serait intenable, absolument intenable.
Oui, non, ça, c'est absolument inimaginable.
Et le CD&V, même chose, hein, le CD&V aussi, il serait très très embarrassé de devoir se faire attaquer par la NVA tous les jours dans un gouvernement aussi,
aussi volumineux, aussi pléthorique quoi.
Comment est-ce qu'on peut faire un accord ? En tout cas, ça va vraiment être très, très difficile. Donc soit c'est ça, soit c'est ce gouvernement de la paralysie, soit c'est la Bourguignonne dont on a parlé.
Pas d'autres solutions.
L'alliance des socialistes, ou alors, c'est des élections anticipées, ce qui serait le chaos. Ou alors, c'est possible aussi, on fait un gouvernement minoritaire.
Un gouvernement minoritaire, comme c'est le cas d'ailleurs pour le moment, un gouvernement de la Flandre, en plus. On fait un gouvernement
minoritaire, je sais pas moi, disons l'arc-en-ciel quoi, les libéraux, les socialistes et les écologistes du nord et du sud gèrent le pays ensemble, mais ils n'ont pas la majorité ensemble à la chambre.
Donc ça veut dire qu'il faudra au cas par cas négocier avec certains partis de l'opposition leur appui à la chambre des représentants pour voter les lois.
Ça va être très lourd hein, franchement, ça va être très très lourd.
On avait parlé de ça, oui, au moment de la crise politique en décembre dernier.
C'est pas impossible. Les gouvernements minoritaires, ça existe en Europe.
En Espagne, oui, par exemple.
Oui, ça existe. Donc les gens survivent comme ça, mais c'est loin d'être la solution, c'est loin d'être la solution idéale quoi.
Oui, on peut difficilement pitcher ça comme une solution.
Voilà, mais on va peut-être vers ça, un gouvernement minoritaire ou la bourguignonne ou le gouvernement à huit. Enfin, ou des élections anticipées, mais...
On voit clairement que...
Le plus facile, le plus gérable, ce serait la bourguignonne. Mais ça demande juste que le PS et le NVA acceptent de gouverner ensemble et c'est ça toute la difficulté.
Oui oui, même là, on se demande si tiens, une partie du... Oui, ça demanderait effectivement un grand effort vers le social de la part de la NVA.
Sinon, on pourrait facilement imaginer une fuite de l'électorat du PS vers le PTB, justement, qui lui serait encore plus radical, encore plus anti-NVA.
Oui oui évidemment, parce que ce scénario pose des problèmes énormes à tout le monde. Tout le monde serait extrêmement embarrassé dans ce bazar-là.
On va bientôt devoir se quitter puisqu'on a largement dépassé les septante minutes. Je t'avais promis et je tenais à ce qu'on parle un petit peu de ton métier, du journalisme politique.
Une question qu'évoquait,
Pierre-François Lovens il y a un an quand je l'ai reçu dans ce podcast. Un aspect qu'il évoquait, c'était le caractère en fait ben catholique de cette institution qu'est ce journal qu'est La Libre Belgique.
Il avouait même qu'autrefois, c'était un petit peu le journal du CDH, aujourd'hui beaucoup moins, disait-il. Mais malgré tout, il affirmait tout de même : « Ben oui, nous sommes catholiques ici à La Libre Belgique.
» Ah, tu ne te reconnais, je te vois hausser les sourcils.
La ligne n'est pas catholique. Enfin, c'est l'histoire du journal. Bon, je ne sais pas ce qu'il a dit parce que j'ai pas écouté.
Il a dit : « Nous sommes catholiques. »
Voilà. Bon, l'histoire du journal est clairement liée au catholicisme, mais ça fait quand même quelques années que, voilà, qu'on a une sensibilité, c'est vrai, plutôt,
comment dire, plutôt ouverte aux chrétiens, certainement, on donne la parole souvent à des,
je sais pas, des penseurs chrétiens, par exemple, mais comme d'autres journaux le font,
à des évêques, comme d'autres journaux le font, mais en tout cas, dans le traitement par rapport au CDH en tout cas, ça, je peux le garantir,
il n'y a rien de catholique dans le traitement de la formation politique.
Donc nous, on n'est pas un journal d'opinion, hein, ça, c'est clair. C'est le passé.
Vous n'êtes plus un journal d'opinion.
On n'est plus un journal d'opinion, on ne veut pas le redevenir. Aujourd'hui, il n'y a plus lieu de faire des articles orientés dans un sens ou dans l'autre.
Aujourd'hui, on livre des faits, on les vérifie, on livre des analyses objectives, le plus clinique possible. On reflète la vérité, la manière dont on la perçoit.
C'est pour ça qu'on est payé, c'est pour ça qu'on est journaliste.
Mais donc, pour poser la question peut-être de manière un peu plus claire, est-ce que, si autrefois, on pouvait dire : Tiens, le Soir, c'est le journal du pilier libéral et La Libre, c'est le journal du pilier catholique.
Aujourd'hui, tu dirais que ce n'est plus le cas ?
Pas du tout. Pas du tout. Je veux dire, ça n'a absolument, je crois, aucun sens de dire ça. Maintenant, on sent bien qu'il y a une sensibilité plus de gauche dans les éditos au Soir et encore, enfin, on peut en débattre.
Plutôt, je dirais, voilà. Et une sensibilité plutôt de centre droit dans les éditoriaux de La Libre. Ça, c'est vrai. On a une ligne éditoriale qui est pro-entreprise.
Voilà, notre ligne éditoriale, elle est celle-là. C'est plutôt centre droit et plutôt pro-entreprise plutôt que catholique, voilà.
C'est ça. Donc, tu ne définis pas la ligne éditoriale par un label en disant : Nous, on est cette famille-là.
C'est plutôt, s'il fallait la définir, on serait plutôt pro-entreprise et plutôt ouvert aux thèses du centre droit parce qu'elles sont pro-entreprises privées.
Et ça, c'est plutôt, je trouve, ce qui nous définit, plutôt que considérer que le Soir serait laïque et nous catho.
Ça, ça me semble vraiment archaïque quoi.
Ce n'est pas le point de vue que je défendais, mais je disais autrefois, c'était clairement comme ça.
Oui, je sais. Ben, ce serait archaïque de fonctionner encore comme ça aujourd'hui. Ce ne sont plus les lignes de fracture de nos sociétés, je pense.
C'est plus ça, c'est plus là. Le problème ne se situe pas là aujourd'hui. Aujourd'hui, il faut savoir est-ce qu'on est pro pour les entreprises privées, pour le, voilà, mais ça, c'est la ligne éditoriale. Bon.
Il y a une question un peu plus chatouillante, un peu plus emmerdante. Le lectorat de La Libre, Pierre-François Lovens le décrivait comme étant un lectorat plus âgé, plus vieillissant.
Hugues Dayez, on peut parler de La Libre en disant que son lectorat était en baisse, était en fuite, qu'il y avait de moins en moins de lecteurs pour La Libre Belgique.
Hugues Dayez disait ça, en tout cas.
Il a dit quoi ? Il y a quinze ans, alors.
Non, il a dit ça il y a un mois.
Ben je crois qu'il ferait bien d'aller regarder ces chiffres parce qu'au contraire, on est, de mémoire, on a plus six ou plus sept pour cent de ventes.
Enfin, c'est absolument énorme ce qu'on est en train de faire pour le moment. Donc, je dis, moi, je suis juste un simple journaliste, donc je n'ai même pas à défendre les chiffres commerciaux du journal.
Là, à la limite, je m'en fiche, c'est pas mon problème, mais je veux quand même rétablir la vérité, alors.
D'accord, OK. Donc La Libre se porte très bien.
Ben je sais pas si ça se porte très bien, mais en tout cas, les ventes sont en augmentation, ce qui est pas le cas forcément ailleurs.
Et c'est dommage d'ailleurs, hein. Jamais se réjouir de l'échec des autres, mais on est à plus six ou plus sept pour cent d'augmentation des ventes.
Et tu l'attribues à ça ?
Eh ben, au numérique, au virage numérique que le journal a pris, aux ventes...
D'abord, en fait, on a quand même des abonnements qui sont très stables, des ventes au numéro qui sont relativement correctes, donc au niveau du journal papier et au niveau du journal numérique, web, articles payants sur le web.
Là, c'est une explosion et c'est une évolution exponentielle. Donc, moi, je peux pas donner les chiffres parce que je les connais pas par cœur et je suis pas certain que je peux les donner.
En fait, donc de mémoire, globalement, on est à du plus six, plus sept pour cent. Donc, dire qu'on perd des...
Enfin, si Hugues Dayez a dit ça, bah, il s'est complètement trompé.
Oui, il s'est trompé. Alors, il a pas de souci.
C'est pas son métier.
Il est journaliste, hein, quand même.
Il est journaliste, peut-être qu'il ne connaît pas les chiffres. Bon, voilà. Enfin bref, peu importe.
Oui, voilà, un petit glissement.
Voilà. Peu importe. Faut pas trop raconter de conneries non plus. Première chose. Et alors deuxièmement, dire que l'électorat est vieillissant, ben comme dans tous les journaux, je pense, les abonnés papier sont plutôt un public plus âgé.
Maintenant, au niveau des abonnements numériques, ben on touche forcément, et là, c'est en évolution exponentielle, on touche un public beaucoup plus jeune qui est par définition sur son smartphone, sa tablette.
Donc là, c'est un public plus jeune, mais je n'ai pas les analyses sociologiques les plus récentes de nos abonnés, de nos lecteurs, mais en tout cas, ça évolue très positivement dans ce sens-là.
OK. Donc une Libre Belgique dépilarisée qui se porte bien et dont le public est vieillissant pour le papier, mais rajeunit au niveau du numérique.
Donc un avenir prospère, d'après ce que tu nous dis.
Oui, il y a vraiment eu un moment-
Un passage à vide ?
Oui, comme tous les autres journaux. C'est vrai qu'il y a quelques années, c'était beaucoup plus difficile que maintenant. Ça, c'est vrai.
Mais donc, l'avenir a l'air assez étourdissant et positif.
Il y a encore d'énormes, d'autres en parleront mieux que moi. Il y a encore d'énormes enjeux, surtout au niveau numérique, ça, c'est clair.
Mais la situation à laquelle aujourd'hui, elle est absolument inespérée par rapport à l'époque où moi, je suis rentré à La Libre il y a dix ans.
Il y a dix ans, on savait... là, c'était vraiment très très dangereux pour l'avenir même du journal. On ne savait pas si ça allait être encore possible demain.
Mmm-hmm.
Et on est dix ans après et on voit les chiffres. Chaque semaine, c'est la fête quoi, parce que ces chiffres sont excellents.
Et je dis pas ça pour, mais voilà la réalité. Chaque semaine-
C'est une très bonne nouvelle
...chaque semaine, on a des bons chiffres. Alors, est-ce que ça va continuer ? Je n'en sais rien. Est-ce qu'il va y avoir un tassement de cette tendance ?
Je ne l'espère pas. J'espère que tous les autres journaux vont croître également parce que le métier de journaliste est merveilleux et que ce soit Le Soir, L'Écho, les autres journaux, eh bien moi, j'admire
nos confrères qui font un travail génial.
J'espère que tout le monde pourra s'en sortir dans cette ère du numérique. Mais en tout cas, La Libre fait partie des journaux qui sont en train d'exploser sur le numérique.
Nous allons, je crois, clôturer alors cette interview sur une très bonne nouvelle. La Libre se porte bien, je suis heureux de l'apprendre.
Frédéric Chardon, merci beaucoup pour ces septante minutes ou ce plus que septante minutes passées avec moi.
Merci beaucoup. Au revoir.
Toutes mes excuses à nos amis non belges pour qui cet épisode a dû être très soporifique. Je salue votre courage. Sauf imprévu, on retrouve le rythme normal d'un épisode bimensuel bientôt.
Mais histoire de ne pas sortir mes podcasts en même temps que ceux de Fanny, le prochain épisode sortira encore une fois dans seulement une semaine.
Vous en avez de la chance. N'oubliez pas de suivre Septante Minutes Avec sur les réseaux sociaux et de vous abonner au podcast.
C'est gratuit et je mets tous les liens dans la description. N'hésitez pas non plus à m'envoyer vos retours, ça fait toujours plaisir, que ce soit positif ou non.
Et enfin, un gros bisou à Marie, qui m'a dit qu'elle écouterait cet épisode en suant pendant son marathon à Londres. On se retrouve la semaine prochaine. Salut !